[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello this is Sky News today it is 11
o'clock and Welcome to our special
coverage of the local election results
Delight for labor with key victories
over the conservatives so kirstana says
his party is ready for power
make no mistake we are on course for a
labor majority at the next general
election
[Applause]
or was she seen I commit some results
have been disappointing for the
conservatives but says they may progress
in key battlegrounds the message I am
hearing from people tonight is that they
want us to focus on their priorities and
they want us to deliver for them and
that's about halving inflation growing
the economy
and some strong results for the liberal
Democrats as they call time on Rishi C
nag
also ahead this morning a second mass
shooting in Serbia in 48 hours Sees at
least eight people killed and 13 injured
makes perfect the king and queen consort
arrive at Westminster Abbey for a final
rehearsal ahead of tomorrow's coronation
camping out for the crowning moment
Royal Watchers take up their position on
the mall to witness a moment in history
[Music]
hello and welcome to Sky News we're live
in Westminster bringing you full
coverage of a bumper set of local
election results across England it's
really been seen as a dress rehearsal
for the general election and it is
turning out to be a bad day for the
Prime Minister and the conservatives
they've lost control of nine councils so
far across England and that means
hundreds of conservative councilors have
lost their seats while the labor leader
sikestarma and Ed Davey for the liberal
Democrats are both claiming Victory and
also saying the conservatives are
heading for defeats at the next general
election
well we'll be bringing you all of the
results throughout the day we can have a
look now at the latest so this is the
current state of the parties with 62 of
the total 230 councils in so far and you
can see so far this is the councils
labor have gained control of three
councils the conservatives losing
control of nine councils in total the
lib Dems have taken one from them and
others have also taken uh five as well
going to no overall control so a pretty
bad day for Rishi sunak in those early
results and we can have a look at a bit
more detail at some of the councils that
the conservatives have lost so far as
well so these are just some of the
latest of the nine councils lost you can
see one has gone to labor one has gone
to the liberal Democrats a good night
Davey and seven have gone to no overall
control so in other words no one has
enough seats to take control of the
council but that loss to labor it's the
first time ever that labor have
controlled Medway in Kent in its current
form no even in that 1997 Landslide did
labor have control of Medway Council and
the live Dems are also celebrating after
they took one of their top Target
councils Windsor and maidenhead they
took that from conservative control so a
sign there of some vulnerability to the
lib Dems in some of those Southern
heartlands the blue wall as some people
refer to it as well with the story so
far on all of the election developments
here is our political correspondent
robal
a Victory lap in the Tory's backyard the
labor leader in Kent this morning after
winning Medway from the conservatives a
council even Tony Blair failed to take
same story in Plymouth in Stoke up in
Middlesbrough and these are the key
battle line grounds as we go into the
next election and make no mistake this
means that we are on course for a labor
majority of the next election
Stoke on Trent 2 labor taking back
control for the first time since before
the brexit vote a brick back in the red
wall
all Grim news for the Prime Minister
arriving at Tory HQ this morning with
bags of bacon sandwiches for staff the
message I am hearing from people tonight
is that they want us to focus on their
priorities and they want us to deliver
for them and that's about halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting less and stopping
the boats that's what people care about
that's what they want us to deliver and
that's what I and the government are
going to work very hard to do
had a good night too Ed Davies
celebrating in Windsor after winning the
once True Blue Royal Borough in those
traditional conservative heartlands what
I've called the blue wall seats the
Democrats are making big gains and in
our traditional homelands in places like
Dorset and Devon I think will make big
gains as well with many counts only just
starting there's still a long way to go
but if replicated at a general election
these results would see Rishi sunak
ejected from Downing Street and
potentially put labor within touching
distance of government
back in Kent as labor celebrates the
outgoing Tory leader told Sky News he
saw little evidence the Prime Minister
was turning part in fortunes around some
Tories talk about a Rishi bounds is that
a myth I've seen no sign of a Rishi
bounce
um I think he steady the ship which was
desperately needed but well that's a
long long haul back from being able to
return another conservative government
of the next general election which of
course I hope we do
meeting the Australian prime minister
today Rishi sunak will get some respite
as attention shifts to the coronation
but battered on multiple fronts these
results will still likely leave a mark
robow Sky News in Westminster
trying to smile there at Rishi Scenic
with all those coronation Flags behind
him but it's been a difficult night for
the Prime Minister hasn't it yeah be a
prime minister that will be very glad
for the coronation news cycle to kick in
and this one to stop because it has been
a terrible night for the conservatives
um it it looks like it could be beyond
their worst expectations
um a senior Source said to me yesterday
that for all the spin around or we could
lose a thousand seeds that really the
worst case scenario in cchq conservative
Campaign Headquarters was a 700 seat
loss and now it looks like they could
lose a third of all their seats remember
they're defending over 3
300 so it could end up in a worse
nightmare scenario for Rishi sunak and
what is happening to the conservatives
is there was a question going into this
about whether Rishi soon at the change
of power could detoxify the conservative
brand after the debacle of Boris Johnson
and his messy downfall followed by Liz
truss's mini budget that really spooked
the markets and had real life effects
for people in terms of their mortgages
and so on and there was a sense like can
Mr sunak detoxify the brand there's lots
of talk about well you know he's doing a
bit better in the polls
but what this seems to show is that he's
not winning seats in blue wall or
winning back support in remain facing if
you like parts of the Tory shires and
he's also not holding the red wall
ground that Boris Johnson won uh in some
of the heartlands and so he's losing
it's a it's a pincer movement in which
he's been squeezed on both sides with
this awful potentially awful outcome
um for them so a very bad night for the
conservatives indeed it's interesting
because as you say it does feel like
there's that pincer movement is losing
seats like Windsor to the live dams and
then obviously Medway and that um
Titanic labor gain from the
conservatives
this is going to be a critical set of
Elections because everyone's going to be
reading across to the general right yeah
it could even be the last set of local
elections before general election
depending on when it's called has labor
done enough do you think well I think I
think there's a couple of things so now
the first point is only a quarter of
seats have been declared okay so we are
really you know if kirstma has a
mountain to climb in terms of these
results and what that says you and I are
still in the foothills of analysis
that's the first point the other point
to make is that
I've been told that there could be a bit
more patchiness in labors before they've
had a great overnight they've got
momentum that's for sure going into the
morning but are they going to do
slightly less well in the East Midlands
what about the West Midlands they did
quite as well in Dudley for example as
they hoped and and so the conservatives
will have bits to cling on to say you
know the progress of Labor it's not
quite what they're saying but going back
to the big question that is the the big
question the box office set of local
elections is because it could be the
biggest electoral test before the next
general election seven out of 10 voters
in England have an option uh to tell our
politicians what they think of them and
in terms of what labor is saying about
this now they are saying Kirsten said it
very clearly these results show that we
are on calls for a majority government
now that's massive it's a gargantuan
task for labor to overturn the majority
of Boris Johnson back in 2019 teen it
requires a swing bigger than Tony Blair
achieved in the 1997 Landslide just to
give you a sense of the scale of
stormers task and what we're looking at
is can they get to a double-digit swing
once we take all the local election
results and Michael Thrasher and the
psyphologists are you know brilliant
team kind of perform some magic and then
they extrapolate it out and they give us
a projection of national vote share and
of potentially uh parliamentary seats in
a general election and the big question
is can they get over the line at the
moment Michael thrush was saying this
morning really good performance really
solid is it enough we will get a better
sense of it this afternoon but I think
what we can say for sure Sophie is that
what these results are showing is that
if 2019 and that set of locals was it's
a plague on both your houses with labor
under Colburn and the Tories under May
doing really really badly this set is
known as the plague on the houses for
the conservatives with you know big
performances for the lib Dems and labor
and it looks therefore that in some
shape or form kierstama has much more
confidence that he's heading to number
10. minority government Coalition
majority
still to be seen really interesting as
Beth says we're still in the foothills
of our local election coverage today
there's going to be so much more of it
and that picture is going to become
clearer as the day goes on but certainly
difficult difficult days for the
conservative losing to just about
everybody but at the same time questions
uh still to come as the day goes on is
it enough for Kirsten to get that
majority well at the big screen another
person who is punching through uh the
numbers for us today is Ed Conway who's
looking at all the voting data to try
and show us the story behind the numbers
Ed what have we learn so far that's
right Sophie I mean as you were saying
earlier and battle was saying still
early days and we still well let me just
show you the kind of scoreboard of for
the different councils the results we
have so far um what you can see there
well there's quite a lot of red but also
the fact that a lot of this board is
still yet to be announced so we've yet
to get results from about uh about three
quarters of the councils here and that's
going to come over the course of the day
particular Rush happening in the early
afternoon so we should know though as
the day progresses you know how this is
panning out to be and what the data we
have so far does show is well you were
saying it a moment ago have a look at
the big picture here
um the labor party there up by 136 seats
these are seats of course so we're
looking at councilors specifically here
so the numbers are bigger um but labor
up by 136 so far and the key thing is
here in part looking at the change and
remembering as well that this is
comparing it with 2019 which is the last
time that most of these councilors were
up for election which was pretty bad for
both the labor party and the
conservative party but this time around
look at what's happened to the to those
conservative seats so far down by
another 216 and that is looking like one
of their worst performances in a long
time when you look at the councils so
this is that was seats let's look at
total councils which is obviously taking
control of different councils and here
it's a slightly different picture of
course uh labor party up by three
conservatives down by nine so far and
this is so far in the ones that have
been counted so far and then you've got
others going into this no overall
control category so where they don't
either they're independent or there's no
overall control uh in those councils but
I want to just take you and have a look
uh at this map here because here we are
looking at essentially just the the
political picture of the UK and how it's
evolving and what you can see is again
most of these have yet to be declared
you've got some areas that the dark gray
that's no overall control uh over there
but focus in particular over here
Plymouth so that's gone red that's
previously no overall control and over
here as well at Medway so there's Medway
that was conservative before and
actually labor has never had control of
that Council not even in in 1995 so that
was the one just before or Tony Blair's
Landslide and if you have a look at what
was happening there in Medway look at
these numbers here labor up by 13
councilors there so 13x councilors for
Labor uh they're in Medway labor
gainings and conservatives first time
they've ever held control of Medway
Plymouth getting it back from no overall
control a lot going on beneath the
surface there in Plymouth but if we look
at the numbers in Plymouth okay so just
what we're going to have a look at is
vote share so there's Plymouth here's
the vote share okay and this is just
showing you obviously an equivalent
votes are of major different parties in
a sense the Striking thing here is
partly that labor has been going higher
and higher or give or take those bounces
recently but it's more just about this
conservative line which has just created
it's absolutely created in Plymouth this
is Plymouth we're specifically looking
at here and that line there in terms of
the show of the vote down to the lowest
level it might even be lower than in
1995 so disastrous there for Richie
sunac in an area where the conservatives
have previously done uh really quite
well and when you look at these numbers
and kind of take them apart and kind of
try and extrapolate what is happening
beneath the surface here's an
interesting Insight that we've got here
this is showing you obviously it's the
vote share for labor you can see the the
big standout is labor party and how big
those vote Shares are but what we're
specifically looking at here is how that
kind of relates how it correlates with
brexit votes so this is people who were
more keen on brexit areas where you had
higher brexit votes and areas where you
had lower brexit vote so we'll remain
down here more brexit up here and look
at the blue bars in particular so
conservative change in the share of the
votes look the more brexit areas are
still down okay but the more remain
areas are down even further so you're
seeing the Tory vote falling much
further within those areas where people
were less keen on brexit where they're
more likely to vote remain we are seeing
some of these Trends starting to emerge
as I say it is really early in the
counting in the results and in terms of
the analysis but as the day goes on
we're going to get more results we'll
have to see different areas of the
country as well and we'll get more of a
sense of what this means for the
political picture in the UK
thanks very much Ed we going back to
Ed's as those numbers uh come in we've
got another result to bring you
Blackburn with Darwin that's a labor
hold no big surprise but look they
picked up two seats on the council there
the conservative uh dropping uh one it
is a Borough and unitary Authority area
in Lancashire there is a conservative MP
in the area though uh Jake Berry even
though it is at somewhere that we would
expect to go labor in this election but
certainly at science and strength
they're continuing around those former
industrial areas well we can go now to
Newbury and talk to our political
correspondent at Tamara Cohen who is
there keeping an eye on the west
Berkshire uh constituency uh for us for
the council area for us currently held
by the conservatives how are nerves
Where You Are
hi Sophie yes I'm here in Newbury at the
famous Racecourse and it looks like it's
going to be the live Dems racing to the
finish line here West Berkshire has been
in Tory controls since 2005 but it will
only take six seats to change hands for
the live Dems to take control outright
for the first time in 20 years and both
the lib Dems are an optimistic mood here
and the conservatives can see that that
is very very likely to be the case and
last night into this morning has really
been a story for the liberal Democrats
of Games Far exceeding their
expectations we knew they wanted to make
inroads into what they call the blue
wall these south of England conservative
strongholds commuter belt areas where
people weren't that enthusiastic about
brexit and combined with concerns about
the cost of living and housing and local
Services they are looking for a change
of leadership and they've already taken
as we heard Windsor and Maiden head
Theresa May's constituency and made
games elsewhere where it looks like the
lib Dems will take control here in West
Berkshire too now what could that mean
at a general election well the
conservative MP here Laura Faris has a
pretty big majority of 16
000 but this is a constituency which the
lib Dems did hold in the 1990s and
during the Tony Blair years and a
concern for the conservatives as you
could see this pincer movement with not
just labor-making gains but the liberal
Democrats taking seats off them in the
south of England too and certainly the
lib Dems here tell me that if the vote
share is as high as they hope it is then
they will be on course to gain seats
like this in a general election now the
conservatives here say that even if they
lose the council today that doesn't mean
that the writing is on the wall it's not
looking as bad as it is in some other
areas but certainly the picture for the
live Dems is looking very optimistic
yeah optimistic indeed so Ed Davey
having a good night so far thanks very
much tomorrow we'll go back to Tamara
and all of our other correspondents who
are dotted around the country keeping an
eye on some of those interesting counts
for us well we can get a bit more
reaction to the results uh so far
joining us now is the labor mayor for
the west of England Dan Norris thanks
very much for being with us what do you
make of the results in
well I'm really encouraged it shows that
labor is on course for a general
election Victory and it's not just the
size of the votes that are piling up
behind labor but it's where those votes
are happening so they're happening in
the places where they will make a
difference in constituencies that will
determine who will form the next
government so that's really encouraging
from the labor perspective and I also
think what it shows is that labor is has
done an amazing job already coming from
the result we had in 2019 uh kierstama
has brought us to this place now where
we are seriously in contention of
winning the next general election but
it's not done yet there's a lot of work
to do and a lot of trust building the
labor still has to work on
at the same time clearly a good set of
results for labor and a difficult night
for the conceptors but our election and
our analysts are not saying that you're
in majority territory you're in largest
party uh territory if you look at some
of the results you know Bolton hartler
pool still no overall control are you
making enough gains to have an outright
win at the next election
well certainly I think we are and based
on my knowledge of the west of England
as the mayor and as an MP in this area
actually the successor or the
predecessor sorry to Jacob Reese smog
there are now only three Tory councilors
in Jacob Reese mog's current
constituency uh that has never been as
bad as that ever ever ever in living
memory I think it's a sign of how labor
has made real progress but we know that
there's a long way to go this is a
stepping stone to reaching that
objective of forming a government but we
have to take the Electoral with us we
have to persuade them and keep doing
that but it's been an amazing journey so
far and uh kiss Tom has done a fantastic
job and I believe he'll get us over the
next stage which will be even tougher so
we know we've got a tough fight on
I guess the question that some would ask
is look are you just picking up the bad
feeling towards conservatives rather
than setting out your own positive case
for the UK I mean what would you say for
example is the single biggest
Blockbuster labor policy
I think it's the cost of living crisis
is clearly the biggest thing on people's
minds that wasn't what I asked I
wouldn't ask what the biggest issue is I
said what's the biggest policy
oh from the labor perspective it's
actually making sure that you raise
money from the right parts of society so
you do a fair and Progressive uh
windfall tax on those who can afford to
pay the the big oil companies for
example who've made through no um reason
of their own excess profits and you
redistribute them as in a way that is
fair and right uh to regular people who
are really struggling right now and I
think that has resonated very well as
these results show I I agree that the
windfall tax is a very popular policy
that's what all the polling shows but I
do to be honest find it quite
astonishing that whenever I ask what's
the biggest policy it's the windfall tax
I mean this was a policy that's been
around for so many months and you just
think look at the Public Services look
at the state of the Britain you're
constantly telling us how bad the
situation is and the big policy idea is
the windfall tax surely there's got to
be something else
oh well I think there's a whole range of
things but the thing about being in
opposition is that you have to time
those things properly as you approach an
election and I say that as having been
part of the black the Tony Blair
landslide that is exactly the same and I
always ask similar questions as you're
asking me now Sophie about what are our
policies the thing is the government's
in power they're making the decisions
and we are able as opposition to choose
when we come out with our policies and
we will have terrific policies I'm sure
I can assure you that but it isn't for
us to uh to do that that we're not in
power yet and we have to work hard to
get that power
okay is kirstama the next Tony Blair
then he's gonna have to meet he's gonna
he's gonna need to visit me if he's
going to get a majority well I think
you've just got to look at the progress
labor has made it's it's even bigger
than Tony Blair made in the time and the
level of the the poor result that labor
had in 2019 it is an absolutely
unprecedented Improvement in political
history for the labor party it's just an
amazing situation but you are asking me
and labor whether we will form the next
government was inconceivable in 2019
after that terrible general election
result it shows the progress labor has
made but there's still a long way to go
labor still needs to win trust it does
have to come out with those policies
that you're mentioning uh to win people
and persuade them that labor has the
answers to the challenges of the day and
I'm confident under care starmer we will
do exactly that
it's been a good night as well for the
liberal Democrats particularly in some
of those Southern seats in the blue wall
if you like would you be prepared do you
think to go into a coalition with the
live gems no I don't think labor goes
into Coalition with anybody we stand on
our own merits we ask for endorsement
from the public uh I mean it's very
interesting in my area because it's an
area where the lib Dems have done well
in one part of the west of England but
not so well in another
um and so they were hoping for example
to win South gloucestershire that's gone
to no overall control so the lib Dems
have also had a bit of a mixed evening
in some respects and we've actually
taken some seats from the lib Dems on
local councils so it is very very
interesting results but it's mixed
because it's a local election it's not a
general election it's similar in some
ways and we can work out some things
that might be relevant but actually
local issues come into it too and uh so
that's why it's complicated that's why
it's hard to to always put it all
together but what we've done is we have
put on votes labor support in exactly
the areas we need to to form that next
Labor government so we will keep working
hard and we will keep trying to build
trust so that we can deserve a victory
should we get it I okay thank you very
much indeed for talking to us today
you're welcome
and actually that is a fair point local
elections people do vote for all sorts
of reasons there are often local
residence groups for example who can do
very well on Council so difficult to
read completely across to a general
election but at the same time the story
of the day so far is the conservatives
losing to just about everybody good
night for the liberal Democrats and also
the labor party we can in the meantime
hand to Sam Washington now for some of
the rest of the day's news
thanks very much uh Sophie it's not the
only story in town of course it is now
just a day to go in case you haven't
noticed until the coronation and in a
timely boost for the royal family King
Charles is becoming more popular in the
run-up to the coronation that's
according to an exclusive Poll for Sky
News but it's also found that support
for a republic has risen to its highest
level since the early 1990s our home
editor Jason Farrell reports
Kenilworth in Warwickshire a fortress
for King John lancastrians Tudors
Elizabeth the first here you'll find a
giant ruler of royal succession and the
strength of this timeline through our
history has always depended on events
and who wears the crown
these walls may have crumbled but King
Charles inherits a country still
predominantly monarchist however the Sky
News ipsos poll shows support for a
republic is at 25 its highest since the
early 90s so what makes a popular
monarch
I think it's a number of factors
yeah I'd say
it's all about Society where the society
did well at the time was it prosperous
was it politically stable were there
Wars I mean Elizabeth the first for
example has gone down as being called
Gloriana and good Queen Beth and I think
that's because she had such a stable
long reign
and in these times of financial
difficulty our polls shows that more
than half of us feel the Royals get too
much public money I uh respected the
kings of you know
in the past where they'll be out in the
battlefields yeah but
you don't care about it it's a privilege
it's a very privileged accident of birth
thing that costs a fortune to see what
see the lavishness of it and the expense
of it one day I think they represent the
UK all over the world uh what they do
visits bring everyone together the
Commonwealth are they good value for
money I think I think so especially a
slim down monarchy you know sort of
working Royals focus on
londoners and the Scottish are least
supportive of the monarchy according to
our poll this was the queue for the book
of congratulations in Glasgow and here
we found little enthusiasm for the big
day especially with the number of people
striking who should be getting a wage
increase and it's totally well it's
never the right time for them to be
doing it but it's it couldn't be worse
it's got people saying oh tourism people
can watch it but when you've got the
rest of the nation like literally
struggling day to day I think it's
absolutely disgusting personally I know
in Scotland there's probably not the
same banners and Street parties but as a
fan foreign
Italian stuff and have the family around
interestingly over more recent years
Charles has seen his personal
favorability rise from 32 in March 2018
to 52 today whereas his youngest son
Prince Harry who was hugely popular just
five years ago with a 65 rating is now
third most unpopular of the key Royals
just ahead of his wife Megan and prince
Andrew William is the most popular Royal
and William is key to Royal longevity
especially among the 18 to 35 year olds
who are 10 more likely to be Republicans
reflected in the views of these
30-somethings drinking in the Royal pug
in Royal Limington Spa are you
interested in the monarchy no not really
it sounds bad but no I'm not I love the
monarchy however I do feel that King
Charles should have stepped aside and
let will and Kate in They Don't Really
they don't seem to do anything for us I
don't know what
I don't know what it is they do to be
honest apart from bringing money into
London there are lessons in recent and
ancient history for now Britain wants to
maintain its monarchy just a cheaper
version Jason Farrell Sky News
well our Royal correspondent uh Laura
bundock is where you might expect a
royal correspondent to be she's down at
Buckingham Palace morning there to you
Laura there's some hardcore folks out
there already been camping out for days
ahead of the big event
yeah they're right don't be fooled by
the fact it looks empty behind me
they've simply closed the streets all
around the palace now but trust me if
you were to look up the mount which is
to my right this way you will see a
crowd of people these crowds they've
been growing in number over the last few
days the campers they're the hardcore
section are all along the St James's
Parkside they are Camp there through
whatever the weather throws at us over
the next 24 hours but all the way up the
mile nearly as far as admiralty Arch
people are now Gathering they're bagging
these spots because this is what's seen
as the coveted place if you want to
watch the procession uh go to The Abbey
and then of course the procession coming
back from the Abbey as well the last
minute preparations though we're all
underway we know the flowers now are in
stools inside Westminster Abbey flowers
that say a lot symbolic flowers that
represent the king and the queen
consort's love of nature but some
personal touches in there as well
flowers that Camilla had in her bouquet
when she married Charles the flowers
from Charles buttonhole reflected there
as well and on the altar bowels from the
branches of trees including a pair of
trees that the late Queen and Prince
Philip planted to Mark her Silver
Jubilee back in 1978 so a lot of
personal touches in amongst the crowds
as well you'll find the people with that
very rare invite to the coronation
itself I just met one of the 450 British
Empire medalists they've been awarded
that medal for services to the community
and they are being given a seat in the
Abbey 450 of them I met a caterer he's
done catering in the community
throughout covid but he was telling me
about the size of the honor and how much
it means to be in that congregation if
you look back to 1953 it was peers it
was pierces it was Coronet wasn't it and
and capes and the like this time is the
sense of the king wanting to reflect
modern Britain and talking to Robert a
little earlier with his invite he said
it means a lot to him and to his
community to know that he will be there
and I asked him how he'll be feeling as
the king makes his way in through the
great rest door he said it will be
emotional I'm expecting a few tears and
he'd also say he's got to be there at
half past seven in the morning so he's
expecting to be hungry as well it's a
busy day for the king though as well I
should point out it's got three big
meetings he's meeting heads from other
Realms he's meeting heads from the
Commonwealth and the big foreign leaders
for an invites meeting as well so he's
got a busy day I think the crowds will
be hoping he might come and say hello
that will depend very much on these
clouds because there's quite a gray
cloud gathering over Buckingham Palace
at the moment yeah I hope you brought
your Brolly Lori it looks like you might
need it
now if you want to post a message for
the new king and queen ahead of the
coronation we've got good news for you
because you can do that on our website
all you need to do is scan the QR code
on your screen right now and it'll take
you to our app in the meantime we can
take a quick look at some of those
messages
that have been coming through so far
M Collinson got in touch and wrote big
shoes to Phil Our Queen is much missed
but I know she has taught you well
follow her lead but move with the times
and we are all behind you your majesty
and Lizzie Kent sent these thoughtful
words wishing you fortitude great humor
compassion and companionship to Reign
for the good of your people through rain
and shine
and forensics 16. he saw the humorous
side of this and uh said I do hope his
pen is working properly
do you keep those uh messages coming
through if that's uh your inclination
now in the meantime let's go back to
Sophie who's going to bring us more
reaction to the local election results
thanks very much indeed Sam we do have a
new result to bring you it is South
gloucestershire now this has been under
conservative control since 2050 but they
have now lost control of that Council
it's gone to no overall control and you
should be able to see the uh full uh
results because the conservatives have
lost 10 seats on the council they've got
23 now the lib Dems have gained three so
some of those suits go into the dams and
the other six going to the labor party
so again just really illustrating the
story of the night here of conservative
seats being lost to both labor and the
liberal Democrats I just want to bring
in our political editor Beth Rigby
because you're hearing some rumors about
another quite well big Council for the
conservatives yeah this one wasn't on my
watch list either which makes it even
more interesting because we've been
through all the councils but we're here
in that Stratford upon Avon a
conservative council could go to the
liberal Democrats now the local MP there
is Nadeem Sahar who you'll know him as
the former party chair and chair and
former Chancellor I've been told that
there's been quite an aggressive
campaign there over his tax Affairs I've
been told from some of the rivals of the
conservatives that there's a lot of
local anger over the issues around his
tax Affairs and what he didn't didn't
declare and then having to pay or settle
with hmrc and that I'm hearing and this
is from sources on both sides so the
Tories and the liberal Democrat sources
suggesting that that council could go to
the lib Dems now that would be a big
deal the conservatives they have 26 of
the 41 seats there currently the lib
dams are only on 10. so has there been a
quite aggressive I imagine local
campaign by the liberal Democrats that
could see Stratford upon Avon go into
the liberal Democrats fascinating yeah
really big deal if that does happen the
first time that the conservatives would
have lost the majority since the early
2000s if that does happen as Beth's been
hearing well joining us now is the
conservative MP for North Somerset the
former chair of the conservative party
Liam folks smiling but it's been pretty
pretty difficult in height right well
it's not exactly unprecedented you know
I've been in politics in the House of
Commons for 31 years we've had a lot of
nights like this over the years
um the the thing is that governments
who've been in office a long time loose
seats in local elections pretty much as
a rule it's disappointing of course and
it's a shame to lose very dedicated
people who've given so much to uh to
local Civic life but these things are
part of it and and I think you also have
to see it in perspective I was doing
these programs in 2019 2019 it was
predicted we would get a 28 share of the
vote
six months later in the general election
we got 43.6 then 80 seat majority so all
I'm saying is I'm not saying that they
they're not uncomfortable but you've got
to try to see it in some sort of
historical context at the same time
though this is more than
Jews isn't it and you're talking about
time I remember 2019 and it was such it
was I think it was your second worst set
of results and Theresa May left shortly
after them because they were so bad
well I think for me what would have been
worse would be if we'd had these
elections six months ago and in the six
months since
in charge the party has recovered in the
opinion polls these results would be
more six months ago and the government
and we're moving towards if I prime
minister's five priorities this election
there's not gonna be a general election
next month or anytime soon the
government's got maybe 18 months to make
it especially its economic case to the
voters of this country and there are
other differences as well just worth
pointing out turnout being one of them
in local elections you get a turnout we
think this one's around about 33 general
elections are around about 70 in 2019 it
was predicted if you went on those
results that the other parties apart
from labor conservative and lib Dem
would get 25 of the vote but they've got
nothing like that so you've got to be
careful about extrapolating local
government results International ones
general elections are a choice about the
next government you have not a referee
random on the popularity of the sitting
government at the same time and I accept
like there's lots of reasons that people
vote in local elections but this is the
first big test for Rishi sumac at The
Ballot Box right since becoming prime
minister and you've got to say by any
metric he's failed no I think it's not a
great result for us by any means but as
I said this is not a veredict on Rishi
Sunray which is actually seen the
parties uh lateral chances improving
you've seen what's going on in the
opinion polls over the last few months
whether it's beginning to recover uh I
think it there's no doubt that you've
seen some improvements in both labor and
lib Dem but even in places where labor
have been doing well places like
Plymouth they their increase in the
votes here wouldn't give them a majority
in a general election no at this point
given everything that's gone on if I
were the labor party I wouldn't be over
celebrating these results I'd be
wondering why
if things are as bad as they say they're
not getting the sort of results that
would put them into a majority in the
house get them over the line there right
it would get them to be the largest
party and it would it would see you guys
well 18-month site from a general
election where our government has been
in office for 13 years and you can't
even at that point look like you might
win a general election outright isn't a
great position when I was a conservative
party chairman
um I wouldn't have thought if we'd been
in the same position it was much of a
cause for jubilation and Bethany if
you've got any questions I mean Liam
you're you're a former party chairman so
my first question really is if these
were the set of results that you
presided off you'd be pretty gutted this
morning I mean if you cut through the
spin this is a bad set of results then
you would be worried nice party Truman
and opposition and being party chairman
then it's quite different if you've been
in government for 13 years
um that doesn't happen very often and
governments who've been in for that
length of time tend to lose a lot of the
seats will see how many we lose I've
just been looking at my own local
results we've just picked up
um two extra seats locally out of the
first five declared so there's still
quite a bit to go in different parts of
the country it would be interesting to
see if the pattern is different in
different parts of the UK and it'll be
interesting to what the time note is you
mentioned in there about your Roller's
party chairman I mean Oliver down
resigned as party chairman after the
last set of local election results and
didn't he and these got you've gone down
from there so you should choose the
current party chairman be resigning no
absolutely not as I said I think we're
recovering we've been recovering in the
polls there's no doubt that we hit a
historic low last year and there's no
point in pretending otherwise
um but after 13 years in in government
you expect that there'll be difficulties
in local government
um this morning we were still the
biggest party in local government
despite all those years and uh in in
office and as I said it'll be
interesting to see whether the the drop
in concept of support which we've seen
is mirrored by a rise in labor support
of whether it's going elsewhere whether
it's going to Independence whether it's
going to Greens another minority parties
because it doesn't look as though the
labor party are making the sort of games
that would take them to win a general
election you're trying to put this back
on labor can they win a general election
but let's take it back to the
conservatives because you are being
squeezed by the lib Dems you are being
squeezed by labor I think the clear
thing that we could ask you today is do
you accept that as it stands you are
going to be out of power come a general
election next year no because as these
results stand yeah and as as I said in
2019 I was being asked exactly these
questions
um in 2019 I remember being asked well
it says you'll only get a vote share of
28 surely you must lose the next
election six months later we won a
majority of 80 in the house you know
that's a bad comparison because as I say
if you said Theresa May resigned a few
weeks later Boris Johnson uh came into
power and there was a very different
landscape now you're not suggesting that
Rishi soon go in no to resign with
respect you're missing the point what
I'm seeing is
um things and politics can change very
quickly we are not going to have a
general election in a few months and
it's very possible as we showed in 2019
that the Public's view can change very
quickly and when it came to a choice a
choice between the conservatives okay
and Jeremy corbyn's leaving one more
thing they chose the conservative okay
let me put it another way when the
public are watching this and they have
voted as they have voted 7 out of 10
voters had an option in England to vote
and they have voted how they voted or as
you said they have stayed at home and
then you sit here implying that it's
actually a problem for labor that they
haven't got a majority doesn't it just
suggest to voters that you're not
hearing them you're not listening to
what they're saying to the conservatives
which is we're thoroughly fed up with
you we're going to vote lib dem all
labor but we're not voting for you we've
seen our vote go down no one's denying
that's happened and that's disappointing
but it's not unprecedented and a lot of
Voters who have stayed at home will have
been making their point by doing so but
they haven't been attracted to get out
and vote for Libra or the lib Dems so I
think Justice happened in 2019 there are
a lot of conservative voters who have
been disillusioned and disappointed and
they've decided that they're going to
stay at home but it's not like the
run-up to the Blair victory in 97 where
they went straight over to vote labor
that is not happening how wide are you
by the liberal Democrats we're talking a
lot about labor but just looking at you
know for example in Windsor the council
there you now got your lowest seat total
ever on Wednesday just seven seats half
your previous lowers bath the same
lowest ever and it's the lib Dems making
gains How concerned are you about that
well they already hold bath
um as a parliamentary seat so that
doesn't in terms of the broader
parliamentary arithmetic that doesn't
necessarily make a difference if you're
looking forward to a general election
um I think it's a it's a shame that our
good conservative council is there lost
as I think in Windsor and maidenhead but
you can look at other places where we
have been picking up the odd counselors
here and there the lib dams are quite
good when they get into local government
and consolidating that but remember
they're coming from a very very low base
they only want 10 seats at the last
general election at the same time that
you know I kind of feel we've often talk
about Labor having a difficult uh thing
to do because they have to appeal to
voters in the red wall and also to their
kind of inner city supporters as well
but I will put it to you that now the
conservatives are the ones in a
difficult position because you've got to
defend the red wall and you've also got
to defend the blue wall and they've got
two very different demographics and
different set of policies that appeal to
them you you it's a lose-lose I'm not
sure that's true I think if you look at
the priorities that the government has
set and the Prime Minister has set if
you get the NHS waiting list Stone and
completion comes down the public
finances recovery are recovering these
things matter to people in all sorts of
seats in all sorts of parts of the
country and I think that with the prime
minister with Rishi sunak there there is
someone who the regard as as competent
and coherent and confident and I think
the recovery that we've seen from the
very low point of last year will
continue under Rishi sune stay with us I
just want to break one result that we
have just got in now and it is Warsaw at
Metropolitan Borough Council that is a
conservative hold you can see there on
your screen no change in seats
conservatives 37 labor at 21. and so the
concept of majority probably wouldn't be
under threat but labor not really
showing at signs of progress there in
Warsaw what's your reaction well as I
said just a few moments ago it will be
interesting when we see all the results
to look at what geographical differences
there are what the demographic
differences are
um if if you are the opposition party
and as a former party chairman having
been on the other side of the fence and
in the labor years and always wandering
to to make the case that we would win
the general election
um this doesn't look
um it's labor have made some progresses
let's not deny that but it doesn't look
like a party that's going to win a
general election anytime soon and given
if you look at history that the
government is likely to recover in the
run-up to the election that the economy
is now recovering I think that there's
more than everything to play for and
you're lucky that Walsall came in when
you're in there because that certainly
is a good hole there for the
conservative party there'll be a few
other results that would have been a
little bit more okay
um I want to bring bethan at this point
because to be honest we were expecting
to see labor making progress if not
having the council control but at least
showing signs appropriate I mean that
was a very fortuitous break
in that you are right in that part of
the story I think of the afternoon could
be as well uh how do labor perform in
the western East Midlands now uh Walsall
was an area where they didn't think they
were going to take the council back but
it is a such a hard for Battleground
between the conservatives and labor and
they would have wanted to show some
progress so that is
um of benefit I'm hearing also in the
East Midlands that it's a bit soft for
labor there so what Liam is arguing some
of that point could be made but I've
also picked up that stratford-upon-avon
could fall it's conserve active control
Council that would be an absolute
shocker wouldn't it it would be very
disappointing but I think as you
mentioned there's been a very personal
campaign uh run there the Liberals I'm
afraid are very liable to to run that
sort of campaign and that may work for
local elections with a low turnout it
doesn't work in a general election on
National issues with a much higher
turnout and thank you very much and it
could have you on the program box there
well that uh see the council area of
Warsaw it's certainly a really
interesting one to keep our eyes on no
progress for the labor party in Walsall
one of the ones where they would have
been hoping to have a bigger sign of
breakthrough
a place that labor are hoping to cut
through in is Dover we can go now to our
political correspondent Ali Fortescue at
who is there Ali what are you picking up
hello good morning I mean it is very
early days uh both sides sounding pretty
optimistic it would be a huge blow it's
about to say for the conservatives if
they did lose here they only need to
lose three Council seats to lose overall
control on the council the challenge for
labor is harder they would be to make
seven games to take overall control the
labor leader here telling me he thinks
that's achievable thinks things are
looking quite positive but it would be I
think a symbolic blow for the
conservatives because yes local issues
obviously come up on the doorstep here
and the cost of living traffic
particularly obviously because of the
port of Dover bins these are the sorts
of things that come up on the doorstep
but one of the biggest issues here is
small boats that comes up I'm told again
and again on the doorstep and that
obviously speaks to the broader
immigration policy is Rishi sunak stars
on small boats is his top tough talk
cutting through with voters here so this
I think is a big electoral test for
Russia enact on that National
immigration policy and would be symbolic
if the conservatives were to lose
overall control here and obviously you
know this is part of the broader
landscape in Kent where the
conservatives had have had a very
difficult 24 hour and remember you know
this is
um really pretty secure blue ground 16
out of the 17 parliamentary seats in the
2019 election were conservative so if
labor are managing to make inroads of
scene obviously them take Medway if
um we did see them make advances here in
Dover that would be very significant I
think forecast Diamond but as I say it
is early days here too close to call I
was just speaking to the conservative
Council leader who said that he woke up
feeling very nervous he's feeling a bit
more optimistic now that he's actually
in the room but the labor Leader's
saying he's pretty optimistic too so the
spin's still going on too early to call
I think for now Sophie but it could be
an absolutely fascinating race yes
certainly will be one of those kind of
Southeast urban areas that labor have
really got their is going to be keeping
us across that as the day goes on
and it has been well certainly a
difficult night for the conservatives
that's what we know for sure but there
is a bit of sign of stickiness in the
West Midlands with the seat in Warsaw
labor not making any progress there just
breaking recently and in Dudley as well
conservatives at retaining their control
too we can now go to Sam Washington for
the rest of the day's news
thank you very much Sophie now the
king's coronation ceremony takes place
in just 24 hours time at Westminster
Abbey joining me now from Buckingham
Palace is baroness Scotland who is
Secretary General of the Commonwealth
now baroness Scotland good to see you
this morning we know that the King has a
big meeting today with Commonwealth
leaders what else is planned to Mark the
relationship with the Commonwealth over
the weekend
well this morning we've had a wonderful
meeting with a small island developing
States and then we have the leaders
meeting this afternoon in Marlborough
house there's going to be a reception in
the Buckingham Palace this evening all
of that taking place before the
wonderful ceremony tomorrow where his
majesty King Charles III will be crowned
so there's a huge build up but what's
been exciting is to see leaders coming
from the four corners of the world to
celebrate this and for all of our 56
members of the Commonwealth representing
2.5 billion people 30 percent of whom
are 60 of whom are under the age of 30.
they're all here because back in 2018
when the question was raised sadly as to
what might happen or should happen when
her majesty Queen Elizabeth II died who
would become ahead of the Commonwealth
because it was not a hereditary
principle the ministers and the leaders
then at chogham in London in 2018
decided made the decision that in that
event his majesty would because of all
the work that he had done over the years
for all of the commonwealth countries
that he should be the next head of the
Commonwealth and that was probably a
great moment because this was not
something that he inherited it's
something that as a result of his own
hard work dedication and support for the
Commonwealth the leaders felt was the
appropriate thing to do and that he
would be the best person to continue the
Queen's Legacy and in his own right to
be head over Commonwealth
notwithstanding all of what what you
just said of the manifold pressures on
the monarchy um you've got to count at
the Commonwealth up there pretty High
the Australian prime minister for
example has not ruled out a referendum
on making the country a republic and
Jamaica could hold one as early as next
year so there is pressure
well you know it's really important that
we all remember that when the new
Commonwealth was created in 1949 it was
created because eight countries in the
Commonwealth no longer wanted to be
Realms but wanted to become republics
and from that eight we now have 36
republics and we've got five countries
in the Commonwealth who have their own
monarchies we've got 33 small states 25
Island States and the most recent
countries to join the Commonwealth had
nothing to do with the Empire that's
Togo and Gabon they'd both been part of
the French family and now they've come
to join us in the Commonwealth because
of our values because what we're doing
on on the rule of law good governance of
climate change remember that it was the
Commonwealth in 1989 through zlankari
declaration in Malaysia decided that we
had to concentrate on climate because it
created an existential threat so it's
all those things that bind our
commonwealths together
Scotland but it does sound a bit like an
advertisement
um you can't deny there is pressure
there is pressure brewing in the
Caribbean and if Australia breaks with
the monarchy that's a pretty big
democracy that may well pave the path
for others
yep but but what I'm saying is it has
always been so Barbados left uh just
recently but they remained a member of
the Commonwealth they remained grateful
that the fact that King was going to
continue the head so it will continue to
happen every single Commonwealth country
who has democratically listened to the
people decided what they wanted to do
they've all stayed as full members of
the Commonwealth so I think it's really
important for us not to amalgamate these
two things that every single country has
the right to self-determine what would
you Advocate the king does to maintain
good relations and there's been a lot of
tension about the colonial past and I'm
also wondering whether he needs to
deploy perhaps uh Prince William
no no I I think if you look at what has
happened every time his majesty has
visited any of the commonwealth
countries he has been warmly welcomed
the Commonwealth creates a platform for
us to discuss some of the most difficult
questions facing the world today not
just the Realms the world and our
leaders are going to come together today
to do just that talk about the young
people in our Commonwealth what's the
future of the Commonwealth how are we
going to make it a smarter more relevant
Commonwealth and I think to create a
false Dynamic which puts people in
different positions doesn't actually
reflect the truth of where we are and
this world is a very difficult place a
very fractious place and what I know
from having been Secretary General since
2016 is that Commonwealth has remained a
beacon of good sense and an opportunity
for people
for people together and to cooperate
Scotland it's really good to talk to you
this morning thank you for your time and
you thank you so much
well we are here to guide you through
all of those local election results uh
today over conservatives losing control
of nine councils and total labor picking
up three so far the lib done is picking
up at one Beth what's your kind of main
takeaway so far
well bad night for the tour is how bad
can it get
um strong for labor but are they going
to be tilt into a minority government or
an overall majority and we're going to
have a fascinating set of results coming
up soon herefordshire Ross and Dale
Gates had Manchester worth in so plenty
still uh to go at Warsaw as we just said
encouraging for the conservatives a
little glimmer of hope in the west midst
there and we're certainly are going to
be ramping up when it comes to those
results they are going to start coming
in thick and fast we will be here with
you at sudu stay with us here on Sky
News for all of those critical local
election results in England
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our special coverage of the
local election results
thank you
Delights for labor with key victories
over the conservatives secure stama says
the party is ready for power
no mistake we are on course for a labor
majority at the next general election
[Applause]
admit some results have been
disappointing for the conservatives but
says they've made progress in key
battlegrounds
the message I am hearing from people
tonight is that they want us to focus on
their priorities and they want us to
deliver for them and that's about
halving inflation growing the economy
two one
and strong results for the liberal
Democrats as they call time see what we
did there on the conservatives
also coming up this afternoon a second
mass shooting in Serbia in 48 hours Sees
at least eight people killed and 13
injured
the king and queen consort arrive at
Westminster Abbey for a final rehearsal
ahead of tomorrow's coronation
camping out for the crowning moment
Royal Watchers take up their position on
the mouth to witness a moment in history
[Music]
hello and welcome to Sky News we're live
in Westminster for you bringing you full
coverage of those crucial local election
results across England and what is
turning out to be a pretty bad day for
the Prime Minister and the conservatives
so far they've lost control of nine
councils across England and that means
hundreds of conservative councilors
losing their seats but the labor leader
kirstalmer and also Ed Davey for the
liberal Democrats are claiming Victory
and also claim the conservatives are
heading for defeat at the next election
well we're bringing you all the results
throughout the day we can have a look at
the latest state of the parties this is
where we are currently at you can see uh
there that the labor party uh have taken
control of 115 seats and three councils
the conservatives have lost 199 seats so
far they've also lost control of nine
councils so live dem's picking up 53
Council seats and they are also in
control of an additional Council as well
and some of these certainly are some big
seats the live Dems taking control of
Windsor and maidenhead their best
results their Theresa May's constituency
there too labor taking control of Medway
for the first time for the conservatives
that was even not under labor control
during the 1997 Landslide victory for
Tony Blair so a difficult night for the
conservatives losing seats to both the
labor party and the liberal Democrats in
different parts of the country and we
can look in a bit more detail at some of
the councils of the conservatives have
lost now so of the nine councils one's
gone to labor one has gone to the level
Democrats and seven have been lost to no
overall control the loss to labor the
first time ever labor has controlled
Medway in Kent in its current form it
was it was 1997 that it was formed the
liberal Democrats are also celebrating
after they took one of their top Target
councils Windsor and maidenhead so a big
Target there for the liberal Democrats
well with the stories so far and all of
the election developments we can go now
and listen to our political
correspondent robal
a Victory lap in the Tory's backyard the
labor leader in Kent this morning after
winning Medway from the conservatives a
council even Tony Blair failed to take
same story in Plymouth in Stoke up in
Middlesbrough and these are the key
battle line grounds as we go into the
next election and make no mistake this
means that we are on course for a labor
majority of the next election
in Stoke-on-Trent 2 labor taking back
control for the first time since before
the brexit vote a brick back in the red
wall
all Grim news for the Prime Minister
arriving at Tory HQ this morning with
bags of bacon sandwiches for staff the
message I am hearing from people tonight
is that they want us to focus on their
priorities and they want us to deliver
for them and that's about halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting lists and stopping
the boats that's what people care about
that's what they want us to deliver and
that's what I and the government are
going to work very hard to do
had a good night too Ed Davey
celebrating in Windsor after winning the
once True Blue Royal Borough the results
last year at the local elections when
the Democrats made the biggest gains now
this year when we're on for shooting
regains you know that really shows that
that blue wall of conservative MPS is
under threat from the liberal Democrats
with many areas still counting there's
still a long way to go but if replicated
as a general election these results
would likely see Rishi sunak ejected
from Downing Street and labor the
largest party though the scale of any
Victory is still deeply uncertain
back in Kent as labor celebrates the
outgoing Tory leader told Sky News he
saw little evidence the Prime Minister
was turning part and fortunes around
some Tories talk about a Rishi bounce is
that a myth
I've seen no sign of a Rishi bounce
um I think he's steady the ship which
was desperately needed but that's a long
long haul back from being able to return
another conservative government of the
next general election which of course I
hope we do
meeting the Australian prime minister
today Rishi sunak will get some respite
as attention shifts to the coronation
but battered on multiple fronts these
results will still likely leave a mark
robhouse Sky News in Westminster
let's bring in our political editor Beth
Rigby who's here with us and if you're
wondering uh who our other lovely lady
is this disguise election analyst Dr
Hannah bunting who is going to be here
with me and Beth to provide some
analysis as well so Beth and it feels
like with these nights right you get
spin from both sides they've picked
individual councils or even seats to
just say look actually we're doing great
ignore what everyone's saying cutting
through all of that what do you think
the story is that you're you're
absolutely right and then you get into
the weeds and you go well Walsall stuff
and actually what we need to do is zoom
out and watch the big picture and I
think there's sort of three elements to
this set of local elections the first
one is clearly do the national polls
what it's been shown a massive labor
lead does that translate at The Ballot
Box into circus starmer becoming the
prime minister at the next general
election so really we're seeing art
labor on course
to win a general election and then if
you decide the results suggest that
they're on course to win in then it's a
question of are they an outright
majority winner is it a minority
government do they need a coalition
right so there's that question I mean
really this is the story of are we going
to have a change of government next year
after what will be 14 years of
conservative power and just to jump in
we have had a breaking a result just as
you were talking which I think
illustrates your point well in Anne
Hatfield District Council now the
conservatives losses to no oral control
in 2019 but they regained it in 2021 and
look they have lost it again to no
overall control so the conservatives
there have lost three seats the lib Dems
are picking up one labor picking up two
and this is important isn't it Beth
because this is the home of Grant chaps
yeah so that that one was we were
looking to see whether that would go uh
to no overall control and it has so
that's kind of a little moment of the
conservatives going backwards again and
you know labor will like that because
that will be a key Battleground where
they'll feel that they need to make make
inroads
um but going back to the big picture so
that the first question is can labor win
a general election then the subtle
stories within all of this subplots if
you like which are playing out kind of
in Stereophonics really is number one
the lib Dem fight back but in the blue
wall because this is a set of elections
in which last local elections it wasn't
the Tory shires where we were getting a
sense of how were the heartlands feeling
about the conservative party and now
we're getting a real sense of it and
what we are seeing is this massive
erosion of the conservative vote in in
some um key ground and and actually
what's even more interesting about this
which Hannah will know much more than I
do is that it's a high watermark for the
libdoms they did really well in 2019 on
this set of Elections and we were
looking at weren't we like 150 or more
games that would be great now I'm
hearing that they they think that are
going to get 300 or more seats right so
that will really really unsettle Tories
in the South I'm hearing that sorry
Heath Michael gove's part part of the
world that is neck and neck the libderms
could take that you know we've just
talked about Stratford upon Avon so
that's the other story then the third
story of course is is the detoxification
of the conservative brand Under issue
now the thing that they've made a big
play on for months we're competent
focused on delivery he's not a flashy
prime minister but he you know the
public trust him and his ratings are
going up is that playing out and the
evidence is it doesn't seem to be
because they are losing pretty much
everywhere I think as Liam Fox and we
were talking about there could be some
crumbs of comfort in the West East
Midlands a key uh conservative labor
Battleground
um but for Rishi I mean for the
conservatives to say it would have been
much worse six months ago and that's
what they're saying to me as well you've
got to put it in the context of they've
got you know they could be heading to
lose a third of the seats that they are
defending if they get into territory of
losing a thousand Council seats it
doesn't matter they can't write that
offer midterms Blues I mean that is
beyond their worst nightmares so put
yeah they a good night for them would
have been five to 700 seat losses or
around 500 they could have said midterm
Blues they they can't spin that as this
and and and really for all the spinning
we will get about well really it's about
can labor former majority government the
conservatives will be coming out of this
thinking
this idea that we can close the gap
close the gap before the next travel
election is is feeling further and
further Out Of Reach as all the results
come in I thought it's really
interesting to hear Beth talk about the
kind of blue wall if you like rather
than the red wall and that could be the
focus at the next election and just
looking at you know well in a half or
for example you know Grant chaps has got
an 11 000 majority do you think that
actually because of some of the results
we're seeing in the South even though
it's relatively healthy majorities could
be a bit shaky yeah yeah absolutely the
liberal Democrats are really showing
themselves to be a key Challenger to the
conservatives you know our benchmarks
were the sort of the bottom end of
comfortable for them was 50 seats and
we're only a fraction of the way through
the results and they've already got
those 50 seats so yeah they may well get
those 300 and the wonderful Michael
Thrasher
um said that if the conservatives are
down 200 by breakfast then they are on
course to lose that thousand so yeah it
looks like it really is going that way I
mean also talking are really interested
to hear what you said because talking to
some lib Dems about what they think
might be going on as well is there's a
couple of things which is post covered
as a lot of people left cities and and
went to the shires maybe labor voters in
cities in big like big combinations that
they are voting tact tactfully uh
tactically practically and also
tactfully I'm not very tactful but
and they are
um they are maybe voting lib done
because they actually want to ask that
that's what the lib Dems are say did you
see that as a emerging pattern or is it
lib dem's protest vote local elections
they always outperform and then and then
it reverts back in a general yeah well
there definitely has been demographic
change as you say we picked that up in
their census which was part way through
the pandemic sort of 2021 and there's
been even more change since then so I
think that's definitely a factor but
they they were the key Challenger anyway
to the conservatives in those areas and
if the conservatives are losing seats or
losing voters then they're probably
directly going to the liberal Democrats
plus benefiting from that demographic
change yeah really interesting to hear
from both of you we have lots of more
big picture and small picture from us as
the day goes on but let's go now to the
big screen because Ed Conway is looking
at all of the voting data to show us
some of the story behind the numbers Ed
what do we know so far there's a picture
starting to form isn't it Sofia I mean
it's still early as you say but we're
starting to kind of fill in this
departure board as it were of councils
with the colors of which party is
controlling them of course let's you
know not forget here we're talking about
uh 230 councils across England
specifically England for these elections
Northern line does have elections coming
up in a couple of weeks but this is
England we're looking at here but it
does give us a sense maybe of that
bigger picture as well as having local
issues as well as you know some changes
in terms of the composition of your
local area if you live in these areas
we're also getting a sense of what's
happening in the bigger picture about
kind of public appetite for the
political parties and when it comes to
that well there's the big picture and
that's going to continue to kind of fill
in as the day goes on and we get more
results Rush coming up in the next few
hours I think
um but let's look at the picture of
councils just kind of giving you a sense
of who is doing better and who is doing
worse and when it comes to the overall
control of these different councils will
labor there uh with 22 so far so of the
ones we've had declared so far about
quarter that we've had thus far but the
key thing is looking at the change here
so it's looking at the labor being up by
three in terms of control of councils
but the conservatives down by 10. look
at that look at how far back that bar
goes and I think that's one story that's
pretty clear as for quite how good a
night and indeed a day it has been for
kirst armor um that's starting to emerge
at the moment it's looking pretty good
same for the lib Dems as well but what
is it no doubt is that for the
conservative party it's been pretty
disastrous and when you have a look at
some of the places that we're talking
about here here's the map so I showed
you the kind of departure ball before of
different councils but here's the map of
England and all of the places that are
being contested at the moment as you see
most of it still light gray so we get to
get some of these numbers but Focus for
a minute uh on here that's Windsor and
maidenhead there so that is now yellow
as you can see there that's now gone
kind of yellow orange for the lib Dems
and if we have a look at those numbers
in uh Windsor and made a maidenhead
actually over here
here's the interesting thing okay so the
overall control has gone uh from the
conservatives to the lib Dems and you
can see the numbers of councilors there
so 22 712 but here's the really striking
thing when you look at the change look
at how big those numbers are the lib
Dems gaining 13 the conservatives losing
16 16 of their counselors uh down to
seven that's the Striking thing it's
those numbers but what's happening
beneath the surface that's giving us a
sense of just how people's appetite is
shifting a similar thing as South gloss
should that number those numbers just
coming through relatively recently so
that was conservative that's now gone to
no overall control so the conservative
is losing control over the council again
it's the same thing so labor up by six
uh lived ends up by three but the
conservatives down by tens so beneath
the surface as well as seeing those
overall changes in control you're also
seeing what's happening in terms of who
people are voting for and what's
happening with different councilors
across the area you know a lot of these
areas which typically the conservatives
had hoped to hang on to they're not
doing well at all and when you look at
the kind of Trends you know what is it
that might be leading to that well a lot
has happened in the last year alone but
still there's one Trend that seems to be
prevalent which is there is a kind of
brexit pattern here so 2016 may feel
like a long time ago it is really a long
time ago but still those kind of changes
in the different population and
different parts of the country who were
keen on brexit so this is basically
looking at vote share and the change in
the vote share by areas which were
pro-brexit okay so pro-brexit down to
areas that were kind of pro remain and
what's striking here particularly look
at those blue bars a conservative change
in the votes look it's down a bit in Pro
the most Pro brexit areas is down quite
a bit more in the kind of slightly
pro-brexit areas and in Pro remain areas
it's down a lot more you're seeing that
kind of trend the more remain areas uh
are the less Keen they are on the
conservative party and the more they're
swinging away from them and Swinging
towards the labor party look at those
bars for the labor party it's just
incredible really the change in the
share of the vote there so big changes
happening here still a lot more results
yet to come as I say we are about what a
quarter of the way not quite a quarter
when you look at the number of seats uh
other way through and there are going to
be many more uh numbers and indeed
results yet to come and we'll bring you
those over the course of the next coming
hours so so still lots more news uh yet
to come on these local elections and Ed
will be keeping across all of those
numbers as they come in well Ed was just
saying there wasn't he about how the
conservative votes doing particularly
badly in remain areas well let's go to
one of those who voted Romaine West
Berkshire uh Tamara Cohen is in Newbury
for us what's going on where you are
yes Newbury is one of these areas where
the conservatives have been in control
of the council since 2005 but the
liberal Democrats are pretty optimistic
of taking the council outright for the
first time in 20 years they haven't
actually started counting yet in West
Berkshire but the liberal Democrats are
in buoyant mood and their leader tells
me that they think they've done more
than enough they only need six seats to
change hands to take control and I think
they will get more than that though
perhaps not a stunning a result as we've
seen for example in Windsor and
maidenhead where the lib Dems took the
council there but this is very much what
Ed Davey called blue wall territory area
that wasn't that enthusiastic about
brexit or Boris Johnson and is an
affluent voters but there is has been a
cost of living squeeze combined with
concern about housing and concern about
the environment and all that has come
together to make a lot of people feel
that there may well be a change of
leadership here what could that mean for
a general election well look served with
MP here Laura Farris has a big majority
of 16
000 although the boundaries will be
changing a bit next time but the live
Dems did win here in the 1990s and
during the Tony Blair years so you could
see this pincer movement where labor do
very well in the general election but in
seats where they're not really in
contention the live Dems do very well
too and that's going to make things very
difficult for the Tories so live dem's
confident of taking the council here in
West Berkshire from the conservatives
and perhaps if the vote share is high
enough that giving them the momentum to
deliver an offset later down the line
thank you so much tomorrow tomorrow
they're keeping you across one of these
key areas where the live Dems are making
inroads on the conservative boat we can
get a bit more reaction now to the local
election results so far because we're
joined now by the labor MP and also the
shadow economic secretary to the
treasury tulip steak thanks so much for
being with us well look you're up 117
seats and you're also up I think it's
three councils pretty good set of
results you must be happy yeah we are
very happy so looking at results like
Medway about Plymouth Stoke-on-Trent
we've also won in places we really
didn't expect to win so the
Middlesbrough mayor Chris Cook wasn't
expecting to win and that was quite
unexpected people we spoke to on the
ground said we thought we'd do well but
not win overall I've just heard that the
conservatives are leaving the count in
Swindon so I think that probably signals
that that's looking quite optimistic for
us that's a key Battleground in the
general election
so we've also looked at some of the
seats where we're not just taking seats
away from the conservatives but we are
taking seats away from the greens and
lib Dems York is one of them that's
looking very interesting again we
expected to make some games in Europe we
didn't expect to get overall control I
don't we don't have the full results yet
but yeah I know amazing sort of results
and a Real Testament to the hard-working
councilors across the country so I'm
very pleased for them yeah we're
definitely keeping an eye on some of
those seats and it's a bit of a a mixed
picture though isn't it right and I'm
talking in particular about the West
Midlands and more Soul no change at all
you'd certainly be hoping to make a bit
of progress uh there Dudley again I
think you've picked up a couple of seats
but it's not really the Breakthrough in
every area of the country that you'd
need if you're going to have a landslide
right if it's translated if the votes
translate and we're eight points ahead
it will be a labor majority government
obviously we'd have to look at Scotland
and have the expected recovery because
there is there is a question on that
because our election analysts Professor
Michael Thrasher believe that you're not
on course for a majority you're on
course yes to become the largest party
and the conservatives obviously to leave
government but it is a completely
different calculation isn't it to get a
majority and you're also supposing
what's going to happen in Scotland yeah
I mean no one can say what's going to
happen in Scotland as part of that aside
I think the polling does show that we're
going to do what do well in Scotland but
you know no one can say and I think what
I would say to that is for a start it's
hard to predict exactly what will happen
as we know the polls have shown sure
which is why which is why we're looking
which is why we're looking at some of
the experts to look at that and if since
the 1950s you know you haven't formed a
government with less than 40 seats in
Scotland but if I mean obviously
Scotland like I said we have to assume
that the expected recovery will happen
there but even looking at all the
results here today and all the results
overnight for a start people vote
differently in national and local
elections that certainly happens in my
patch but even if you look at lib Dem
vote share so in 2017 and they had 17 I
think of the overall vote but when it
came to the general election they only
got eight percent so there's obviously
different ways of people voting the
other thing I would say I just want to
jump in if I may just because we've got
a new result coming in that I want to
ask you about as well uh Burnley now
Burnley has remained under no overall
control labor gained one seat
conservatives gaining a c as well I
think and then a seat down for the lib
Dems now this is quite significant right
because in 2019 labor lost it to no
overall control you only need four gains
to take majority uh control but you
didn't manage to get that so that bit of
a disappointing result for you I mean
obviously we would want to get overall
control in any situation but at least
you know it looks like
um we've won two scenes the other thing
is one of the things you've got to look
at is are the conservatives winning
seats from Independence because I looked
at the results in 2019 which was
obviously the worst set of results
because we hadn't left the EU like they
had thought we were going to Theresa may
obviously resigned but a lot of the
seats were lost to Independence if
they're winning those seats back and
they're trying to pretend that's a huge
Victory I mean I don't think it is
because those were strong labor seats
they had a strong preservative seats and
they shouldn't have lost those seats in
the first place so I don't know if you
know did they win that from well I'm not
sure but I know that there was a ukip
candidate last year and some Burnley and
padaham Independence in Burnley so we're
not clear exactly where the distribution
was from I was looking at some of the
results and I was seeing some of the
conservatives winning seats from
Independence which they should have
never lost in the first place and then
globe thing about how they've won a
seats
no I think the bar is quite low if
you've lost it in the first place and it
was meant to be Die Hard Tory I'm not
sure it's such a boast in that case I
mean I'm just I'm just looking at the
Burnley result and it wasn't necessarily
expected that label would take that
Council but I think it speaks to the
bigger point that is beginning to emerge
in lunchtime into the afternoon which is
is Labor's performance a bit too patchy
I mean is it going to be the
barnstorming taking uh making progress
across the country or is kiss stormers
labor still struggling a little bit more
in the East Midlands West Midlands and
parts of the red wall and it looks like
that that could be
um an emergent story
about I think overall the results look
very positive we one see it's like
something which I'm not I'm not sure I
would I mean we have to we'll get a full
picture I think by the end of this
evening we would have a full picture of
everything but so far I do think we're
winning seats in places we didn't think
we would there's seats like I know
everyone keeps going back to 97 but one
thing we didn't actually hold even in 97
so it's different seats and I think
different analysis the other thing I
think I I should really mention because
it's a lot of the feedback we're getting
from people is the number of people who
were disenfranchised from voting as well
and I feel like that's what to be talked
about as well we're getting messages
from people saying that and you'll see
that on social media nurses who turned
up to vote with their NHS ID and were
turned away because of their ID and you
know I'll make this point by saying I
don't want to politicize this because I
feel like people should vote regardless
obviously I want them to vote labor but
they should vote regardless but taking
away someone's Democratic right to vote
I think is something that we've just got
to discuss us before the next election
because our voter turnout is not very
high anyway and on top of that if we are
restricting people from voting because
of the lack of ID I think it's
disgraceful how disappointed are you by
the strength of the libderm performance
because it's not just Labor's night days
that you're having to share the glory if
you like with the lib Dems it's not
great for you is it well the libdam
local election results normally do not
translate nationally for them and and
that's been shown in election after
election so I think I just um quoted
that statistic when I first came on
which was that they got 18 of the vote
share in 2017 but if you go to the
general election it only translated into
seven percent of the wheelchair so I
think they do do they over perform in
local elections certainly the ones that
I've seen But in general elections I'm
not sure that will translate so I think
it's going to be a fight between the
conservatives and labor I don't think
the lib Dems will really perform quite
that well in general election so I'm not
too worried thank you and one seats to
bring your Council I should say Nazi to
bring you um as we were talking that's
gateshead it's a labor hold no surprise
there but labor actually lost uh two
seats on the council they're still at
very healthy 49 but the lib Dems they're
picking up two seats from the labor
party which puts them on 17 so more I
guess evidence of what we were
discussing that actually it has been a
pretty solid performance from the
liberal Democrats to say the least
there'll be lots more from us as the
afternoon wears on and all those results
continue to roll in but for now let's go
back to Sam Washington for the rest of
the day's news
thank you very much Sophie now you might
have noticed it is just a day to go
until the coronation and in a timely
boost for the royal family King Charles
is becoming more popular in the run-up
to the coronation that's a CL according
to an exclusive Poll for Sky News but it
also found that support for a republic
has risen to its highest level since the
1990s our home editor Jason Farrell
reports
Kennelworth in Warwickshire a fortress
for King John lancastrians Tudors
Elizabeth the first here you'll find a
giant ruler of royal succession and the
strength of this timeline through our
history has always depended on events
and who wears the crown
these walls may have crumbled but King
Charles inherits a country still
predominantly monarchist however the Sky
News ipsos poll shows support for a
republic is at 25 its highest since the
early 90s so what makes a popular
Monarch well I think it's a number of
factors of course but firstly I'd say a
monik shouldn't really kill persecute
its subjects that's obviously a clear
thing but also it's all about Society
whether Society did well at the time was
it prosperous was it politically stable
were there Wars I mean Elizabeth the
first for example has gone down as being
called Gloriana and good Queen Beth and
I think that's because she had such a
stable long reign
and in these times of financial
difficulty our polls shows that more
than half of us feel the Royals get too
much public money I respected the kings
of you know
in the past where they'll be out in the
battlefields but
you don't care about it it's a privilege
it's a very privileged accident of birth
thing that costs a fortune to see what
see the lavishness of it and the expense
of it one day I think they represent the
UK all over the world uh what they do
visits bring everyone together the
Commonwealth are they good value for
money I think absolutely especially a
slim down monarchy you know sort of
working Royals
londoners and the Scottish are least
supportive of the monarchy according to
our poll this was the cue for the book
of congratulations in Glasgow and here
we found little enthusiasm for the big
day especially with the number of people
striking who should be getting a wage
increase and it's totally well it's
never the right thing for them to be
doing it but it's it couldn't be worse
it's got people saying oh tourism people
can watch it but when you've got the
rest of the nation like literally
struggling day to day I think it's
absolutely disgusting personally I know
in Scotland there's probably not the
same banners and Street parties but as I
found we're going to celebrate it just
at home quietly watch it on Italian
stuff you have the family around
interestingly over more recent years
Charles has seen his personal
favorability rise from 32 in March 2018
to 52 today whereas his youngest son
Prince Harry who was hugely popular just
five years ago with a 65 rating is now
third most unpopular of the key Royals
just ahead of his wife Megan and prince
Andrew William is the most popular Royal
and William is key to Royal longevity
especially among the 18 to 35 year olds
who had 10 more likely to be Republicans
reflected in the views of these
30-somethings drinking in the Royal pug
in Royal Limington Spa are you
interested in the monarchy no not really
it sounds bad but no I'm not I love the
monarchy however I do feel that King
Charles should have stepped aside and
let will and Kate in they don't really I
don't seem to do anything for us I don't
know what I don't know what it is they
do to be honest apart from bringing
money into London there are lessons in
recent and ancient history for now
Britain wants to maintain its monarchy
just a cheaper version Jason Farrell Sky
News
now final preparations for the king's
coronation are taking place with just 24
hours to go well earlier King Charles
and queen consort arrived at Westminster
Abbey for rehearsals ahead of the
coronation ceremony
and we've been given a look at some of
the ancient crown jewels which will be
used during the coronation that's
including the two crowns that King
Charles will wear one of which weighs
over two kilograms there you go a lot of
bling isn't there about that crown
now uh if you are so inclined and you
want to post a message for the new king
and queen ahead of the coronation you
can do so on our website all you need to
do is scan the QR code that's on your
screen now and it'll take you to our app
uh in the meantime we can take a little
look at some of the messages that have
been coming through to us uh so far well
not to us but uh via US uh Lolly sent
these kind words wishing the king and
queen a fabulous memorable coronation
day looking forward to watching this
historical moment good health and
happiness to you both and all of the
royal family God Save the King and
casbel sent her wishes to the king as
well good luck for tomorrow it's a day
to celebrate and we all know you will
make us proud It's Great Britain at its
best
and then Stephen also wrote we will be
watching the coronation from South
Africa as you are crowned his majesty
King of England your big day has finally
arrived let's just hope the very dean of
Westminster gets the crown the right way
around
thanks very much uh Sam well let's just
bring you the current state of the
parties when it comes to the local
elections we have a bit of a sit rep
find out where we are so far so it's
been a good set of results as I said the
least for the labor party they are up
117 seats they've also gained control of
an extra three councils and
conservatives are down over 200 seats
now so a really difficult night for
Russia's Scenic they've lost control of
10 councils too and good performances
from the liberal Democrats up 55 seats
and the greens as well who are up 18
seats
they're hearing rumors Beth aren't we
from the labor party about another seat
uh that is not even I'll be honest it
wasn't even in one of my kind of to
watch seats uh this is East
Staffordshire what are we hearing it's
in my watch this but I should give a
shout out to Molly and Izzy because
they've made the best document I've ever
read on these things but
um the this is a fascinating seat
because labor as you said look we
haven't had it confirmed health check
but labor are calling East Staffordshire
uh for them a labor spokesperson saying
it's a hugely significant result that
confirms were on calls for a majority
labor government we've been going
backwards in Staffordshire and recent
general elections with this game and Our
Winning State we're making real progress
in the places we need to win the
election I checked my doco my document
and that is a currently East Africa is a
conservative control Council they have
25 seats and labor have ten so that is a
huge gain if it comes through I wouldn't
imagine they put it in a spokesperson's
uh voice uh if um they didn't so and
again I think what this is partly about
um uh narrative management because we've
just spent half an hour talking about
East mids West mids being patchy and
they're coming back saying actually
we've got a huge gain here and so that
is a really significant seat for like
that'd be delighted wouldn't they have
if it's correct yeah yeah absolutely you
know it's sort of uh industrial area
where they had been losing to the
conservatives for uh you know a number
of years now so since the brexit years
and if they're starting to make gains in
those areas as well as the other areas
that we've seen and as you said even
though there were quite a few marginal
Wards there when you look at the total
number of seats that 25 to 10 if that's
been overturned then yeah that's a big
victory for labor we've got another
Council that has declared and that is
Rossendale it's a labor hold they had 22
seats now on the council so they've
gained three seats in Rosendale the
conservatives have lost at three seats
as well the greens up one two and that's
a district in Lancashire in England so a
real key battle around there and also
that that I mean look we expected labor
to hold that but of course
um Jake Barry the former
um conservative party chair he's the MP
in that seat so uh a labor Council a
conservative uh MP and one seat that
will be clearly in uh kirstalmers sites
come come the general election
uh well really interesting to see those
results come in we're going to be
keeping our eye on like East
Staffordshire one in particular I think
we can cross now to Stockton I believe
and talk to our political correspondent
Liz uh Bates I think that is right
grapes uh Liz what's going on where you
are
yes so we are here in stocks on teaser
what you can hear behind me is one of
the wards being announced so we'll wait
to see that the announcements have been
going on now for the past few hours
we're in an area of the country here in
the Northeast where the labor party has
been absolutely hammered over the past
few years the conservatives have made
inroads here they've taken constituency
seats they've got MPS here they've lost
councils and if you remember as well of
course that Hartley pool by-election in
2021 a massive swing to the
conservatives they need to start taking
back places like Stockton on teas now
this council is quite interesting
they're defending 22 seats here if they
win just if they if they win just 29
seats they will take overall control of
this Council take this Council back
quite interesting
given the national picture you might
think that might be quite easy to do the
feeling on the ground I think is fair to
say is that it could be a bit more of a
mixed bag here labor may be gaining a
few the conservatives look like they
might gain a few as well we haven't had
any switches yet but let's ask um the
labor MP for Stockton North Alex given
the national Alex Cunningham sorry I
should say given the national picture
you would expect to be making big gains
here in such Don teas but tell me how
you're feeling what what you you know
more what's going on on the ground how's
everything going well first of all I
would say huge congratulations to my
colleagues in Middlesbrough and Hartley
pool who we've taken the mayorality in
Middlesbrough and we've now taken
control of Hartlepool Council here is
very much the mixed bag that you've just
described I'm waiting to see what the
actual results are but it looks as
though we're facing a situation where
we'd probably be Even Stevens at the end
of the day
it's not starting to feel here at all
like kind of landslide territory is it
for labor and you you need that when
you're looking at the next general
election you have an enormous mountain
to climb particularly in areas like this
in the teas Valley you have to win back
areas like this so is this a bit
worrying we're always going to have
challenges in an area where you know a
mixed economy like this we have a very
different groups of people in different
parts of the constituencies so we've got
to work hard for every single vote
that's what we've been doing during
these council elections but of course
they're very different because we have a
tremendous independent Factor here in
Stockton and you know that doesn't
necessarily fit into any general lecture
result in the future but the rest
assured over the next 12 or 18 months we
will be fighting on to try and get every
single boat we can
given that you're not making big gains
here potentially not making big games
here and you've been working really hard
what's standing in your way
well I think the independent factor is
important but I also think there's some
local issues we've seen some some
changes in the area and people have
voted accordingly and I understand that
but uh no a clear message to us if we
don't uh win overall control of the
council we've got to work even harder in
the future to make sure that we do
is Kia Sama a problem in this area
because when I speak to people here they
don't love the labor leader they did
really like Boris Johnson many people
around here wish that Boris Johnson was
still prime minister do you think here
storm is a problem well Boris Johnson
isn't even prime minister anymore I mean
his own party dealt with him the way
they should have done people still like
him though but they really don't like
his Diamond that much oh yes I mean I
had like circuses and clowns but uh you
know people look at every light to to
like who they wish but in an area like
this we know that we've got to continue
to fight hard we've got to win seats
like Darlington and Stockton South and
redcar but you know on the Bears on the
basis of some of the results I've seen
already you know we're actually on
course to do quite well
Charlie's Cunningham
um so as you heard there that is the
labor MP for Stockton North I think the
expectation here is that maybe that
incredibly positive picture that we've
seen for the labor party across the
country is not going to be replicated
here in stockton-on-tees given how
people are feeling here on the ground
the results are still coming in and we
will bring them to you as soon as we get
them
thanks very much Liz we'll be going back
to Liz to get more reaction just as seen
as that constituency in the council area
declares we can get a bit more reaction
now to the local election results so far
joining us now in the studio is the
former MP Luciano Berger co-founder of
the pollster jail partners and oh no I
think uh James Johnson we're going to
speak to at later apologies let's talk
to Luciano for now shall we uh what do
you make of the results then well so far
it's been dire I think for the
conservances some real terrible results
and a really positive for the labor
party and for other parties across the
country as well do you think it is the
story is more about the conservatives
doing badly or labor doing well and I
guess I'm asking this because yeah look
you look at the results the
conservatives are losing all over the
place but and labor really cutting
through in the way that they need to if
they're going to be on calls for a
majority well let me take both elements
of those questions let me start first
and foremost with the conservatives the
conservatives sought to manage
expectations in advance of these
elections today saying they would lose
around thousand seats the idea that was
that was going to be a positive thing
you know they already lost at the last
elections in 2019 just over it was 1 300
seats uh this would be bad news for
Rishi sunak to to continue to lose seats
bearing in mind the polling at this time
is high for the conservatives than it
was back in 2019 and they've really
targeted those independencies and then
just not making the gains if we look at
the numbers that they should be doing
today so they said they endeavored to
set expectations but setting
expectations of a loss of that of a
thousand was was pretty pretty poor and
and they should be gaining seats at this
time of course it's incumbent therefore
on the opposition to be picking up seats
at this time I'm really moved by the
results that we've seen so far if we
look at what the labor party needs to do
at this time in advance of the general
election that we expect will come next
year it needs to be picking up seats in
the South or they've done that in
Plymouth the party needs to be picking
up seats in the Midlands and we've seen
that taking over stoke the council there
the party needs to be picking up seats
in areas like more than Kent and that's
happened in Medway and areas like
t-sides are really very important and
the party so far and the results that we
have have taken back a control of the of
the melty there so I think we've got
some really strong positive indications
of what the party will do I don't want
in any way fall into the Trap of
downplaying some of the games you've
made like Medway first time ever a
controller that Council for example but
you mentioned the West Midlands there
it's a bit of a mixed picture there
right you know didn't make any progress
from all sold it make as much progress
you might have hoped to in Dudley are
you really cutting through in the way
that you need to to get that big swing
that you have to get if you're going to
have the majority well it's very closely
because the conservatives in their
messaging today have sought to point to
councils like Sandwell somehow being you
know not good enough later which I'm not
doing but yeah it's like Warsaw for
example that you could say aren't good
enough for labor and what will be really
important is to assess on a constituency
by constituency basis those
constituencies that the party needs to
win in order to to today in order to win
at the next general election and every
indication is uh there's very many
Midland seats at the party is going to
be picking up if you were looking at it
on a constituency basis like Dudley
South for example very very important I
just want to zoom out for a bit because
lots of our viewers will know you for
being somebody who left the labor party
under Jeremy corbyn has been forced out
and it would say right because of the
attitudes within the party at that time
you've since rejoined Under kirst Armor
how different a party do you think it is
now compared to the party you left I
mean the reason why I left the labor
party was because I couldn't sleep at
night I rejoined a couple of months ago
because I can now sleep again and that
was important for me personally I think
we're looking at a party that's very
very different today under the
leadership of soccer than it was uh
three years ago certainly if we look in
terms of what the party's done to
address the very specific issues that
led me to leave around anti-Semitism we
know from the equality and Human Rights
Commission that the parties on
everything that it was mandated to do in
order to ensure that was taken out of
special measures and it was returned to
where it should be a party that stands
up for equality and fights against
anti-racism that was an important moment
and we've also seen a massive sea change
if we look at the the membership of the
party who the activists are and you know
there's there's a new Cadre of the Next
Generation fantastic to see so many
young candidates standing and these
little council elections some really
fantastic uh general election candidates
have been selected right across the
United Kingdom this is is a party that
is in for me is is completely a change
and it looks completely different than
it did when I left in February 2019.
you've you've just read joined Lisa and
I hope you don't mind me asking you
about this Diana but she's currently in
an under investigation yes for
anti-semitic remarks she made she's
apologized unreservedly
um how are you feeling about Diana but
do you think that kirstalmer can allow
her to remain in the party and still be
true to his word of of stamping out
anti-Semitism in the labor party
it's like obviously it's been very
closely to what the customer has said
throughout the entirety of his
leadership so far and particularly at
that moment just there was a two Sundays
ago and he said well first and foremost
it wasn't just the words he said but
it's the action that he took so Not only
was he very robust in his response to
what emerged and from the letter that
was published and that Diane had written
but also the action he took to suspender
and the investigation that's now
underway by the chief I I don't know
what the outcome of that investigation
was but in terms of taking that for
Swift action and being very robust his
response I think it was absolutely right
that he did that would you personally be
comfortable remaining in the party with
her if if that's what the he he decides
to do to allow her to stay well it's
it's not him it's his
investigation and I don't want to
pre-gess or presuppose what the outcomes
of that investigation where I would
judge him on what's happened so far and
I think it was absolutely the right
course of action to suspend at that time
I think it's only right that uh that we
with that investigation is allowed to uh
carry out and and we see it through its
course
um thanks so much for coming on and
talking about the local election results
we're going to have many more throughout
the day a couple of ones to bring you
now because we have Noel sleep has just
come in at now labor holding on there so
they have retained control of nosley
they did lose two seats though
interestingly they were to the green
party uh say the labor party there on 31
seats down two though I mean comfortable
majority sure but the green party
picking up two seats uh from the green
party and that comes off the back of
gateshead where they lost two seats to
the liberal Democrats well we can bring
in now the co-founder of the pollster JL
partners and former pollen chief for
Theresa May James Johnson I just want to
pick up off the back of that nosy result
there saw labor just dropping two suits
to the green party look we shouldn't
read too much into individual areas or
individual seats but is there a bit of
pressure uh going on to the labor party
from the lib Dems and also the greens
yes there's a little bit of that though
it seems that broadly speaking the uh
sort of pressure from Independence or
that Dem seems to be hurting the
conservatives a little bit a little bit
more
um labor do need to watch that Left
Flank especially in a general election
well they'll need to make sure they
mobilize uh the turnout of their
supporters but the story generally of
these results so far is the
conservatives losing support to labor
but also to the lib Dems and other
parties and labor broadly either
improving or staying steady uh on last
year's performance and therefore being
able to make quite a few games from the
conservatives
says first shall we because it felt that
the conceptives knew that it's always
going to be difficult but they believed
that there was a small Landing zone for
Richie sunac to win the next general
election
looking at these results where you say
they seem to be losing to both the labor
party and also the lib Dems is that
Landing Zone still there
look I think the I think if you're the
conservative party trying to look for
positive signs and these results is is
not straightforward um these are clearly
bad results clearly good results for
labor I think the big question is can
they turn things around in the next 12
to 18 months and I think that is a
bigger question mark we have seen a
governing Conservative Party come back
from a labor performance like this after
the local elections in 1990 when John
Major won in 1992 and I think it's
completely fair to say
um uh that those uh allies of Richie
sunac are correct when they say that
these results would have been a lot
worse six months ago he's half that
labor polling lead that he inherited
from Boris Johnson and Liz truss so
that's the big question now can they
turn it around and obviously number 10
are counting on competence on counting
on the ability to say that they're
delivered results
um and a weak brand of the labor party
and that's the one thing I think I'd say
here is that when you hold nationally
and you do focus groups nationally there
are still very significant hesitations
about Kirsten and in these elections
Kirsten wasn't on the ballot come a
general election Kirsten will be on that
ballot and it will be more of a high
stakes decision for people to back
Independence greens lib Dems rather than
one of the two main parties so we may
see a general election could be similar
to this but it could also be quite
dramatically different well I have to
say as you say whether that does play
out or not when it comes to the labor
party
um there does seem to be a bit of a
Divergence of opinion shall we say about
whether this is a performance that is
good enough to win a majority labor say
yes it is they are absolutely on track
to gain a majority in the next general
election our analysts say hang on a
minute they may be the largest party but
it's short of majority what's the truth
yeah I I think that is over reading to
say that they're on they're on track to
win the next general election uh these
are local elections as I say they take
place in a different a different setting
voters are thinking about different
things a poll that we did uh on the day
of the release released on the day of
the day of the voting yesterday show
that the biggest three issues for voters
uh were hospitals buses and potholes
um those issues will be particularly
hospitals they will be important at a
general election but voters then will be
thinking about who's going to be the
next prime minister who's best to run
the economy now look there's no doubt at
all these are good results for labor
um they're the best results in local
elections for Labor uh since they left
power under Gordon Brown more than a
decade ago
um but nothing is written in stone uh in
elections and I think that's what I'd
sort of you know stress is that over the
next 12 18 months voters are incredibly
volatile they change their minds easily
in focus groups I see voters change
their minds you know within sort of 15
20 minutes of saying one thing or
another so it was quite worrying to hear
thank you
don't don't blame the voters they've got
a lot of stuff thrown at them they've
got a lot of different arguments and
things to consider
um but uh it's it's certainly um these
these local elections certainly suggest
it's Advantage labor but I don't think
it's quite all over yet yeah okay thank
you very much for your analysis a couple
of breaking results to bring you North
Hertfordshire has remained under no
overall control but I want to take you
particularly to heinburn in Lancashire a
district council now that has remained
under no overall control labor would
have been hoping to make some gains
there to show the party was on track for
the next election but just let the
conservatives the ones who've actually
picked up two seats off the labor party
so they are both on 16 seats on the
council overall no change in the other
party status but the conservatives
they're picking up two seats off the
labor party Anna is that a surprise
um in some of these areas it will be
down to the local councilors and the
people who were who are campaigning I
think are something that James was
picking up on there is that what you
don't see in the opinion polls is when a
campaign is started and people aren't
just sort of imagining who they might
vote for they're actually coming into
contact with these candidates and then
going into a voting booth and putting a
Name Across next to their name
um it does become a more concrete uh and
more tangible decision that they're
making so yeah we've also seen uh in
knowlesley I think it was
um the labor of lost to to the greens
but these small changes like that are
not necessarily indicative of sort of a
national mood solar Hall in the Midlands
we are also hearing that the consensus
have held on to solar Hall it used to be
a solidly a conservative area there was
a bit of a challenge from the liberal
Democrats that they managed to hold that
off they have she picked up two seats
which means that they have retained
control of solar hole um Beth it's
interesting isn't it because it does
feel as though look the broad story
let's not forget is labor doing very
very well and the conservatives losing
seats but it is a bit more numerous than
that it is and actually I mean what
you're seeing is as more results come
through is that and this has always been
the question really for kirstarma was
could he really kind of win back those
Battlegrounds of the West mids East mids
and the red wall but look they are
making gains and I think uh certainly
it's it's useful for the Tories to be
able to say we've made a net gain of a
couple of seats in Holly um solihull or
your high bun but you know the crawler
of that is we've just taken these stuffs
Etc so and on we go and on they trade I
think look the big picture here and I
think it's really important to to not
get lost in the weeds of it completely
is that and I was just checking with
Hannah as we look at where the state of
the parties are the conservatives are
down 205 seats and look to be by the
close of play down a thousand Council
seats losing a third of their councilors
that is beyond their worst nightmares
you know people who weren't spinning me
um who you know have had conversations
with people in cchq were telling me
yesterday
anything above 700 is a disaster for us
right and it so that is a disaster and
labor on
120 you know and Hannah was saying that
looks like they're on course by the end
of play to make gains of 700 so they're
in the they're in the zone and I think
that yeah there will be kind of
questions about is it a complete
Barnstormer for circus Dharma all across
the country but if your labor you'll be
coming out of this thinking we're pretty
confident that we can take power at the
next German election now what the
configuration of that may be well that's
for us that's for us to talk about that
exactly for the next year that is the
key thing you know the thing is for the
conservatives and and talking to
conservatives about this going into it
there has been a sense and I think you
picked that up from Liam Fox there that
if you can hold the losses and you've
got Rishi sunakin and he's got his
five-point plan and he's going to deal
with inflation he's he's promising on
small boats and he'll say he'll come
waiting list you know the watchwords of
linfox competence and delivery maybe
they could close the gap going into a
general election if you get to single
digit lead for labor you know wish you
soon acts in a you know he's in with a
fighting chance and you know it could be
could it turn out to be the kinnick
where you know in in 91 it was everyone
thought that Kenneth was going to beat
major and he he fell a few seats short
yeah yeah so that's the kind of model
that the Tories are wondering if they
can replicate and I think you know we'll
have a clearer sense as these results
carry on through the day whether that
looks likely or whether we're now
looking a bit more maybe not a de Blair
huge majority but are we looking at a
kind of I don't know David Cameron 2010
exactly which like you say that does
mean a change of government and we are
going to be keeping across all of these
seats uh if you've already seen that
right now you'd be thinking where on
Earth am I going to visit to uh show a
success story it may be that the West
Midlands is the place uh because solar
hole of course they did manage to pick
up two seats there it was where around
that area that Rishi sudex started his
uh campaign at Trail as well I've Just
Seen there the conservatives holding on
to Epping uh Forest as well so a couple
of glimpses of positivity I mean I just
want I mean you know um Rishi soon I did
a clip this morning going into cchq when
only a quarter of the results were
declared and I wonder whether that's the
last we'll see of him today actually to
be honest that may be true that he might
not want to do another clip and he moved
straight onto the coronation could be a
submarine uh prime minister for a couple
of days see you in a moment
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
state it is one o'clock and Welcome to
our special coverage of the local
election results
[Music]
[Applause]
Delight for labor was in key victories
over the conservatives secure starmer
says his party is ready for power
make no mistake we are on course for a
labor majority of the next general
election
[Applause]
Cena commits that some results have been
disappointing for the conservatives he
claims they've made progress in a couple
of areas
the message I am hearing from people
tonight is that they want us to focus on
their priorities and they want us to
deliver for them and that's about
halving inflation growing the economy
two one
[Music]
and strong results for the liberal
Democrats at Davey there could hardly be
more excited
also this afternoon a second mass
shooting in Serbia in 48 hours Sees at
least eight people killed and 13 injured
final preparations for the coronation
continue the king meets Commonwealth
dignitaries at Buckingham Palace for the
Governor's launch
and we'll take a sneak peek at the crown
jewels that are being used in this
weekend's coronation
[Music]
foreign hello and welcome to Sky News
we're live in Westminster for you today
and bringing you full coverage of the
local election results across England
what is turning out to be a bad day for
the Prime Minister and the conservatives
they've lost control of 10 councils so
far across England and that means more
than 200 conservative councilors have
lost their seats the labor leader it's
akistama and Ed Davey for the leader of
Democrats are both claiming Victory and
also saying the conservatives are
heading for defeat at the next general
election we're bringing you all of the
results throughout the day you can have
a look at the very latest state of the
party so this is where we are currently
looking at a bit more detail labor up
117 seats they've also gained control of
an extra three councils and look at that
number in blue the conservatives losing
over 200 Council seats they've also lost
control of 10 councils good night for
the lib Dems they're up 61 seats and one
Council and also a good night for the
green party there are 19 seats so that
is the state of the parties and you can
really see there the conservatives
losing to just about everybody on both
sides to the labor party and also to the
liberal Democrats as well we can have a
bit of a look in some more detail at
some of those councils that the
conservatives have lost so of the 10
councils one has gone to labor one to
the lib Dems and eight to no overall
control now the loss to labor that is
Medway the first time ever that labor
have controlled Medway in Kent not even
in that landslide in 1997 and the lib
Dems are celebrating as well after they
took one of their top Target councils
Windsor and maidenhead signs perhaps of
the blue wall crumbling and with the
story so far on all of the election
developments here's our political
correspondent repel
Victory lap in the Tory's backyard the
labor leader in Kent this morning after
winning Medway from the conservatives a
council even Tony Blair failed to take
same story in Plymouth in Stoke up in
Middlesbrough and these are the key
battle line grounds as we go into the
next election and make no mistake this
means that we are on course for a labor
majority of the next election
in Stoke-on-Trent 2 labor taking back
control for the first time since before
the brexit vote a brick back in the red
wall
all Grim news for the Prime Minister
arriving at Tory HQ this morning with
bags of bacon sandwiches for staff the
message I am hearing from people tonight
is that they want us to focus on their
priorities and they want us to deliver
for them and that's about halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting lists and stopping
the boats that's what people care about
that's what they want us to deliver and
that's what I and the government are
going to work very hard to do
had a good night too at day
at debut Royal Borough the results last
year the low collections when the
Democrats made the biggest gains now
this year when we're on for shooting
regains you know that really shows that
that blue wall of conserved MPS is under
threat from the liberal Democrats
with many areas still counting there's
still a long way to go but if replicated
at a general election these results
would likely see Rishi sunak ejected
from Downing Street and labor the
largest party though the scale of any
Victory is still deeply uncertain
back in Kent as labor celebrates the
outgoing Tory leader told Sky News he
saw little evidence the Prime Minister
was turning party fortunes around some
Tories talk about a Rishi bounds is that
a myth
I've seen no sign of a Rishi bounce
um I think he steady the ship which was
desperately needed but that's a long
long haul back from being able to return
another conservative government of the
next general election which of course I
hope we do
meeting the Australian prime minister
today Rishi sunak will get some respite
as attention shifts to the coronation
but battered on multiple fronts these
results will still likely leave a mark
robhouse Sky News in Westminster
well Beth would be is with us as always
on set but we also now have Professor
Michael Thrasher who is our election
analyst and really this is the moment
that lots of people will have been
waiting for because what we've all been
trying to work out is what this means
for a general election and Michael
Thrasher's been crunching through all of
the data this morning what can you tell
us well we've analyzed all of the votes
1.7 million votes cast in 900 Wards
overnight and because we're only so far
through the overall election results
over 150 councils still to go we've been
a little bit cautious about what we
think is the national estimated share of
the vote but
um based on the analysis of those
results we think that the conservatives
would receive between 28 and 30 percent
of the national vote and remember we're
comparing here with what happened in
2019 which the conservatives got 31 so
they're they're slightly down on where
they were in 2019. we think that labor
will get between 36 and 38 of the
national vote again just to remind
ourselves labor was on 31
in 2019. the lib Dems as we've seen from
the overall results in terms of making
gains and so on that we think that lib
Dems are on on a low of 18 but they may
well push to the magical figure of 20
hence
um that's a pretty good uh election for
them and they've Advanced the most in
terms of where they were in 2019 and
finally the others the others have
proven a little bit intractable in terms
of the independence and the smaller
parties so our range for them is broader
than uh most so it's between 16 and 19
so what what would this mean it shows
about a four percent swing since the
2019 uh results but critically in terms
of looking at the outcome on the general
election you would say the labor are set
to become the largest party but in a
hung Parliament
so a very good result but not quite
getting over the line so the labor party
been saying to us that look they are on
course to get a majority particularly
obviously these seats don't include
Scotland is that plausible
I think from their point of view it's a
rational argument to make but of course
when we are doing this projection we
don't know anything at all about what is
happening to the SMP Vote or apply
companies vote so we just don't know but
it is plausible that again if I was
running the labor campaign if I would do
this because
um it they certainly think that they're
going to win seeds whether they would be
enough seats and as you pointed out
earlier
labor doesn't form a majority government
in the UK without a big number of seats
coming to them from Scotland
um but they it's a reasonable argument
to make that yes we would cross the line
uh with those additional
um SMP seats and can I just jump in with
a couple of councils that have come in
at the time that we've been course
talking firstly East Staffordshire and I
think we can have a look at East
Staffordshire because labor have gained
a Staffordshire from the conservatives
labor are up 11 seats and the
conservatives down eight the lib Dems
also losing a seat there so that they're
a big game for labor party labor gaining
control of East Staffordshire uh Council
um I mean this really does make the
point about what we will see today
overnight the many of the councils that
were choosing their councils were just
choosing a fraction but now we're
looking at whole council elections and
overnight the conservatives will loosen
about one in four a third sorry a third
of the seats
um and they're over uh 200 losses now
but if we look at the overall picture
they go into these elections with uh 3
300. so simple arithmetic says
1100 seat losses which you know was at
the upper end of all of our benchmarking
for the conservatives I mean obviously
I've spent the past few days just
studying everything you've uh said about
all this so I've got all my notes yes
like a girly swap here but I mean in
terms of the projection and in terms of
the seats this is exactly where you were
predicting it would be right
um in that it's reasonable to Envision
labor support running into the high to
Mid high 30s Tories high 20s Tories
might lose a thousand seats labor could
be heading for 700 Gates is this kind of
about as good as you think it was going
to get for kids starmer given how
difficult it is for him to replicate the
kind of performance we saw in Blair in
97.
that's a very difficult question
um and what I focus upon here is that
the story is not just about Tories
losing ground to labor such as that is
and it's very important but the liberal
Democrats are also if you like their
spoiling Labor's party
um in all of this because inevitably
we're going to that the headlines aren't
solely about Labor taking councils
taking seats off the conservatives they
did in East Staffordshire but that's
part of the Midlands where they're doing
it what we're about to see emerging is
parts of Southern England like Surrey
Cambridgeshire Hertfordshire and so on
where the liberal Democrats will kind of
and we already saw that with winter and
maidenhead and Newbury West Berkshire I
should say uh to come so the liberal
Democrats will advance and they they
will you know get um a reasonable share
of the vote which takes away from from
Labor's performance yeah that's it we've
had the other Council that we've had in
as well is Maidstone where the
conservatives have lost control that's
gone to no overall control they only had
a majority of one or Mainstays perhaps
that wasn't the biggest surprise there
were so many I mean the conservatives
started off with 82 councils but so many
of those were vulnerable to uh seat
losses of one two three four
conservative councilors so as soon as
that those kinds of councils tumble into
an overall control not many councils
will switch straight from Medway is one
but not many will switch straight from
conservative labor maybe Swindon will do
uh do it later later on today and Mike
we've talked a bit about
where it leaves him what about the
current prime minister because you know
in the run-up to this one I talked to
conservative strategists and and and
politicians it was all about can Rishi
sooner contain contain the demise
detoxify the party uh encourage voters
to give him another look instead you
know they talked about people slamming
the doors in our faces now they're not
slamming the doors but this doesn't
suggest in any way that he's winning
over any part of the country or any
particular brand of conservative if you
like no but given the circumstances of
these local elections
I wouldn't be at all surprised and of
course what on the on the other side of
the equation you also the conservatives
are in a position with the with the with
this outcome the the national estimated
share of the vote which Caesar
um a parliament where labor of the
largest party but short of an overall
majority
you people are going to start saying to
labor and would you go into a coalition
with the Democrats and that for the
conservatives is exactly what they want
the dialogue to be because that raises
the possibility of you know them saying
to voters look if you vote you know
liberal Democrat you're going to get a
labor Coalition is this really what you
want we need to go to Ali forsuku and
David but before I do I've got one
question I do want to ask you right
because
only um Sunday and Wednesday program all
the time and I'm sure you get this as
well when you're talking to conservative
politicians they say we're always going
to lose a thousand seats that's what
profession Michael Thrasher says like no
big deal can you just explain
the you know why that spin is wrong why
that spin is wrong yes yes well that was
a that was taken out of context I must
say taken out of context but it was the
if you like it was the real low point
for the conservatives if they if they
hit that and the reason the
conservatives ran with it a thousand
losses yes
um is because their expectation was
lower than that because then they come
and say don't they
these people forecast a thousand what
did they know it was half that number
okay but they're in a position now where
they
um and I said uh you know overnight if
there are 200 losses then they're in
trouble because all of these councils
whole councils in the shires are
declaring and Z Staffordshire showed
there 11 was it 10 or 11 uh conservative
losses and it's when you have all of the
councils are up uh for election at any
one time the scale of your losses can be
huge really interesting to talk uh we'll
have lots more analysis from Professor
Thrasher and of course Beth as well
later on this afternoon but let's go to
Dover at shall we our principal
correspondent Ali Fortescue is there and
over it's one of those places where
labor will want to show their making
progress what's the feeling
absolutely if labor can make Headroom
here that is a very good sign this
currently
um is the last East Kent Council that is
conservative control could that change
over the next few hours safety well
we've had three results in so far the
first a labor hold the second was
significant a labor gain and there was a
ruption of Applause from the labor
councilors as that result was read out
then third a conservative hold if the
conservative lose three seats here they
will lose overall control of the council
so it won't take a huge amount for that
to happen and that would be very
symbolic I think because of course the
local issues matter here you know people
that I've spoken to since I've been here
about buses bins the cost of living
traffic particularly because of the port
of Dover but a big issue that comes up
again and again on the doorstep is small
boats so the government's broader
strategy the national policy on
immigration I think does matter here so
this is going to be an important litmus
test for how Russia's United's policy on
small boats is going down with the
public as I say you know it is still
early days but there has been one
conservative seat lost to labor labor no
this is the sort of place they need to
be gaining ground if they are to have a
big landslide in the next general
election and of course the picture in
Kent has been absolutely fascinating
overnight you were talking about
conservative losses of course they've
lost Medway Maidstone worth saying too
in the last couple of hours and the
leader at fanet Council has lost her
seat that of course a former ukip
Council so a big loss in thanet there as
well Kent really you know traditional
pretty traditional
um blue ground 16 out of the 17 MPS here
were conservative in the 2019 election
these are the sorts of places that
Richard snack really needs to be holding
on to when the whole country goes to the
polls so the result here I think will be
very important at the moment there is
still early days and all sides saying is
too close to call but there has been one
conservative seat lost to the lane party
interesting stuff Ali thank you very
much indeed Ali Fortescue will be taking
us through all of those results coming
in in dafa well it's been a pretty busy
day for us so far you're watching Sky
News at one coming up how popular is
Kelly Charles we'll find out what the
public think about the Royal Family
[Music]
God
Save the King
[Applause]
[Music]
over us
thank you
join together to celebrate
the his coronation of King Charles III
on Sky News
[Music]
foreign
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy News
Daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
Conway try and make sense of at the big
numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whenever you get your podcasts
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back it is now just one day to
go until the coronation and in a timely
boost for the royal family King Charles
is becoming more popular in the run-up
to the coronation that's according to an
exclusive poll that was done for us here
at Sky News but it also found there's
always a butt isn't there that support
for a republic has risen to its highest
level since the early 1990s our home
editor Jason Farrell reports
Kenilworth in Warwickshire a fortress
for King John lancastrians Tudors
Elizabeth the first here you'll find a
giant ruler of royal succession and the
strength of this timeline through our
history has always depended on events
and who wears the crown
these walls may have crumbled but King
Charles inherits a country still
predominantly monarchist however the Sky
News ipsos poll shows support for a
republic is at 25 its highest since the
early 90s so what makes a popular
monarch
I think it's a number of factors of
Lee I'd say
it's all about Society where the society
did well at the time was it prosperous
was it politically stable were there
Wars I mean Elizabeth the first for
example has gone down as being called
Gloriana and good Queen Beth and I think
that's because she had such a stable
long reign
and in these times of financial
difficulty our polls shows that more
than half of us feel the Royals get too
much public money I respected the kings
of you know
in the past where they'll be out in the
battlefields yeah but
you don't care about it it's a privilege
it's a very privileged accident of birth
thing that costs a fortune to see what
see the lavishness of it and the expense
of it one day I think they represent the
UK all over the world uh what they do
visits bring everyone together the
Commonwealth are they good value for
money
especially a slim down monarchy you know
sort of working Royals focus on
londoners and the Scottish are least
supportive of the monarchy according to
our poll this was the cue for the book
of congratulations in Glasgow and here
we found little enthusiasm for the big
day especially with the number of people
striking who should be getting a wage
increase and it's totally well it's
never the right thing for them to be
doing it but it's it couldn't be worse
got people saying oh tourism people can
watch it but when you've got the rest of
the nation like literally struggling day
to day I think it's absolutely
disgusting personally I know in Scotland
there's probably not the same banners
and Street parties but as a family we're
going to celebrate it just at home
quietly watching Italian stuff you have
the family around interestingly over
more recent years Charles has seen his
personal favorability rise from 32 in
March 2018 to 52 today whereas his
youngest son Prince Harry who was hugely
popular just five years ago with a 65
rating is now third most unpopular of
the key Royals just ahead of his wife
Megan and prince Andrew William is the
most popular Royal
and William is key to Royal longevity
especially among the 18 to 35 year olds
who are 10 more likely to be Republicans
reflected in the views of these
30-somethings drinking in the Royal pug
in Royal Livington Spa are you
interested in Monica no not really it
sounds bad but no I'm not I love the
monarchy however I do feel that King
Charles should have stepped aside and
that will and Kate in they don't seem to
do anything for us I don't know what I
don't know what it is they do to be
honest apart from bringing money into
London there are lessons in recent and
ancient history for now Britain wants to
maintain its monarchy just a cheaper
version Jason Farrell Sky News
well as you can imagine final
preparations for the coronation are well
underway this morning King Charles and
the queen consort arrived at Westminster
Abbey for final rehearsals ahead of
tomorrow's ceremony
while in the last hour King Charles has
been hosting a lunch reception at
Buckingham Palace with visiting
Commonwealth dignitaries we can see
there the King was joined by other
senior members as well of the royal
family as Princess Royal Prince William
uh accompanied by his wife of course
Princess Catherine meanwhile there has
been heavy rain today in central London
and apparently the Prince of Wales is
hoping it doesn't last
we're praying for the weather tomorrow
[Music]
very British isn't it talking about the
weather well we've been given a look as
well at some of the ancient crown jewels
which are going to be used during the
coronation including the two he needs uh
more than one for the ceremony
apparently two crowns King Charles is
going to wear one of which weighs over
two kilograms
or we can cross live now to beldanati
who's on the mile Bell
um there is a reason we Brits like to
talk about the weather and it's uh
because of days like today if you'd come
to us about half an hour ago we would
have been under brolies we were all
getting soaked our feet don't be fooled
by this beautiful sunshine our feet are
about an inch or two covers in mud here
but that has not uh stopped the people
from coming as soon as that sun broke
out here the crowds went from about one
person deep to if I look now it's
probably 20 or 30 people deep so we've
got enormous crowds suddenly appearing
here a lot of them here since this
morning we have met one group who
arrived actually last night to be here
as you can hear people keep coming past
we get every so often a car driving bus
we get the bells I don't know if you
just heard that the bells ringing a
Silence has now fallen on the crowds you
may be able to to hear that which
normally suggests that something about
to happen I am going to try though and
bring in uh some of the crowds that
we've been speaking to the ladies behind
me who set up uh Camp here earlier this
morning Susie Leslie and Jane I just
want to bring you in here on Sky News
thank you very much for being with us
sorry we're in we're in small cramped
spaces but we're doing what we can and
friends from Minnesota as well behind uh
just talk to us tell us first of all
when did you arrive here this morning
about 9 30 or 10. and how far have you
come oh well I've come from uh
Strawberry Hill Richmond my sister has
come from Newcastle
um my name is come from just down the
road and then much further away talk to
us about about Minnesota Stacy yes so we
come from Minnesota we came about a week
ago but we got here on the mail this
morning about 7 30. we were the second
people to line up on this side so the
second people to line up on this side
why have you made the journey
because it's an experience it's an
amazing experience it's going to be
fantastic I've been here for a few other
Royal events the first one was for
William and Kate's wedding and I
wouldn't miss it for anything in the
world now we can see from your T-shirt
so I don't know if we can see those
t-shirts uh that you you are it's safe
to say Royal fans talk to us about the
the last coronation you remember I
believe am I right in saying you you
we're unable to actually see the last
coronation but you heard it yes I was
nine years old and we didn't have a
television and so my mother let me stay
home from school that day and lay on the
floor and listen to it on the radio and
then when the movie of the coronation
came out my school teacher asked my
parents if I could if she could take me
to the coronation movie and I was over
the moon I couldn't sleep that night or
anything so this is a huge historic
event for me to be able to be here to
actually see it what what does the the
royal family what does the monarchy mean
to you Jane let's start with you
um they've always been a consonant in my
life they've always been something which
I think the rest of the world looks at
the British Monarchy and admires
especially our late Queen and
um yeah I just think that they bring so
much to us as as Brits what would you
would you agree with that Leslie yes I
think they give us tremendous values
certainly King Charles has been ahead of
his time with a lot of his Agriculture
and things like that and I think he's
done a fantastic job and he's going to
be a superb King very quickly will you
all be here tonight camping out
absolutely absolutely look at that
but it
I think rail rain or hail these ladies
certainly will be camping out tonight
let's go back to you Sam
thank you very much uh well if you want
to get involved even if you're not
camping out down there on the mile you
just want to post a message for the new
king and queen ahead of the coronation
you can do just that on our website all
you need to do is scan the QR code
that's on your screen now and it'll take
you to our app uh we can take a quick
look at some of the messages that have
been coming through to us so far as
Sarah wrote congratulations on your big
day I'm sure you are going to serve your
country well and proud I feel very
privileged to be a part of the
celebrations If Only from the comfort of
my home wishing you a fantastic weekend
God Save the King and Natalie sent these
wishes congratulations to King Charles
and queen Camilla I'm proud to be able
to celebrate this historical event and
Jack wrote to say I just want to tell
you both good luck we're all counting on
you let's get more reaction to all of
the local election results which are are
coming in in drips and drabs today let's
go back to Sophie
thanks very much Sam well that kind of
trickle is speeding up a little bit
because we've just had brom's grave in
which is an interesting one the
conservatives losing control of
bromsgrove council that's now no overall
control they've dropped seats to both
labor and the liberal Democrats so
they're down six seats and three of them
have gone to labor two of them have gone
to the liberal Democrats let's bring
Beth in quickly for a bit of analysis
yeah that was this one's a bit of a
surprise I mean I'm just looking at the
results back in 2019 the conservatives
had 17 seats labor had five seats
independent five liberal democats three
so they had 17 seats and they are now
into overall uh no overall control it's
also um javid's parliamentary
constituency now he formed a chance I
mean God he's had so many jobs in
government I can't even have time
he's stepping down at the next German
election but just to put it in context
in terms of that seat it was split it
was joined with Redditch as Broncos and
Redditch constituency in 83 and it's
only ever returned conservative MPS
since then obviously they needed to lose
what four or four seats for it to go to
no overall control because it was split
but yeah so they've lost another what
you would have called kind of cool
conservative territory in roads from
other parties there yeah and again like
not the biggest conservative majority on
bromsgrove but again more evidence of
them shedding votes to both labor and
the liberal Democrats labor have held on
to Manchester Sheffield has remained
under no overall control Sheffield was
always a bit of tussle between labor and
the lib Dems it looks like neither of
those parties has come out decisively on
Top This Time round
well we can now talk to two people who
know an awful lot about campaigning Mo
Hussein who's a UK president of Edelman
Global advisory the former Chief press
officer to number 10 as well as Sonia
SoDo Chief leader writer at The Observer
and a former labor advisor no let's go
to you first
we're hearing a lot of spin right that
this is midterm Blues it's more than
that isn't it
yeah it's much more than that I mean you
get spin at every election you always
get uh each party setting demands with
the other and you get expectation
management and you've heard it you know
the economic picture clearly uh is
really really bad for lots of people uh
there's 13 years of one government
apathy on the doorstep but I think
beyond that there is a lot of uh the
politics and the politics of last year
which have been mostly of the
conservative party's own making uh which
uh are now uh you know being answered
for and people are voting I think based
on that as well so I think it's it's a
lot more than just the usual midterm
blues and it's also not really midterm
either
that's a good point it's not really is
it we are approaching the general
election and these will be a very
worrying set of results for conservative
strategists let's bring in uh Sonia
shall we
do you think that this election is more
about the conservatives doing badly or
labor doing well
well that's a million dollar question
um isn't it safe I mean I think it is
about both
I think the most consistent story though
is the conservatives doing badly and you
can see them losing grounds to both
labor in some parts of the country but
also really significantly to the liberal
Democrats and some of those blue wool
seats where the liberal Democrats are
starting to become more competitive
again so that is a very consistent story
The conservatives doing badly it's as
Moe's just said I think labor have done
well it's a it looks like it's going to
be a good set of results to them the
best set of results since they're a
lasting government
um pre-2010 so that is good news they're
certainly adding on
um they're looking more like a party
that's approaching government but I
think behind the scenes labor
strategists they will be quite you know
they'll be cautious because it these
results certainly don't imply that the
next general election is you know
already in in the bag for labor
um that's partly because their local
election results are really taking place
in England they don't really tell us
very much about what's going on in
Scotland which will be key in a general
election Battleground but also because
you know turnout is much lower than in a
general election so
um you know I I think it's very good for
labor but it's not kind of absolutely
Stellar wow we're looking at a 1997
style kind of landslide outcome in a
general election yet is what I would say
anyway it's quite nice to talk to two
people who aren't just trying to give
you the participate and I have to say um
after a morning of speaking to
politicians of all sides it is quite
refreshing
um Mo there was always going to be a
very small Landing zone for Rishi suno
right considering the last six months
year of the concept of party turmoil do
you think that Landing zone is still
there
I think it's decreasing there's he's
done well to keep various factions in
the party uh relatively happy you saw
that in the make of his cabinet you saw
that in the fact that he derives his
power from his MPS but these results now
will lead to people asking questions
about where is the park going going
forward and is it an issue of the
politics is it the box it drama as he
said over the last few months or is it
actually the policy you have some
conservative saying it's because we
aren't building enough houses we're not
appealing to younger people and some
people saying because we're building too
many houses so this feels much more
existential and I think you already seen
sort of back benches who may not be fans
of uh Rishi zunak but they've just kept
uh kept their part of dry becoming more
vocal around let's go back to a lower
tax Pro growth agenda
um and you still have the economic
constraints that we've had now for many
many months so I think this debate will
rage and these results and if they get
worse which uh think they're likely to
do or just magnify that debate even more
yeah it certainly was certainly be lots
of questions about how best people can
go forward and strategize in the time
that is left before before the next
election Sonia Michael Thrasher our
election analyst has said that based on
the vote shares we're looking at a labor
victory at the election but not an
outright majority and that of course
immediately brings you into questions
about coalitions and about deals with
other parties
um do you think comfortable grounds for
labor
um I mean I think I think it's it's sort
of much more comfortable than it would
have been around the time of the sort of
2017-2019 election particularly in 2019
so then I think you know the line that
if you vote SMP you get Jeremy corbyn as
Prime sorry if you vote you know uh
liberal Democrat then you get Jeremy
corbyn as prime minister would have been
um a much more sort of powerful line of
attack by the conservatives but I think
if you look at the results what you know
the primary driver we're seeing is an
anti-conservative vote people to looking
to get conservatives out you know
whether it means voting lib Dem in some
parts of the country or laboring others
so I don't think that that Coalition
narrative will be you know parties are
never really comfortable talking about
it and you'll see that from you know the
way that lib Dem leader talks about it
the way the labor leader talks about
about it secure stama parties are not
comfortable talking about what they
would do based on particular election
results before the election has happened
but it's much easier than when there's a
very strong attack line because you know
there's a unpopular labor leader and so
the conservatives can say in parts of
the countries where country where they
live Dems May otherwise be a threat well
you better not vote lip Dem because then
you might see a lib Dem labor coalition
government I don't think that that line
attack line is going to have the same
Force um uh in the next general election
and thank you very much indeed really
interesting to talk to you both of you
we've had a couple of results come in uh
while we were talking Preston labor is
held they've gained a seat that
conservatives have dropped one but I
just want to look at West Oxfordshire if
I may because West Oxfordshire has
remained under no overall control but I
just want to have a look at that result
the breakdown in a bit more detail
because you can see that it's pretty
close between the lib Dems and the
conservatives the lib Dems are up three
seats they're now the largest party
although of course short for majority
and the conservatives have lost three
seats they're now on 17 on that Council
the Green's also picking up a seat but
again I think this talks about the
overall story we've been focusing on a
lot today which is not just the red wall
but what is happening in the blue world
what's happening in some of those seats
in the South and Oxfordshire potentially
a Battleground there between the lib
Dems and the conservatives the live Dems
leapfrogging conservatives in West
Oxfordshire and Beth and I'm I'm just
getting in this is from labor I don't
think we've got this confirmed but it
looks like they have taken Swindon now
this is a huge Battleground it was
working starmer launched his election
campaign I mean when you know a Leader's
launching it there you expect them to
win it but I've just got this in from
labor they've made eight gains on that
Council they point out they launched the
campaign there that David Cameron
launched the 2015 conservative Manifesto
in the town of Swindon but it looks like
labor have taken Swindon it was a
conservative
Council they had in the 2019 election 40
of the votes with 12 seats labor had 39
with seven seats it looks like they have
taken it we've got we haven't got it on
our charts yet that is um that that is a
big one and it's the first time in
almost 20 years that Labor's become the
largest party there uh oh and now
they've actually got an outright win so
they'll be delighted by that and look
Sophie the two you know there are two
symbolic uh areas of the country there
was Medway in Kent where Kirsten ended
the campaign and there was Swindon uh
where he kicked it off and they have
taken those councils so
um they will be I'm sure coming on the
Airways to talk a lot about that so
Swindon has gone uh to labor a massive
election Battleground Swindon yeah it
really is and as Beth was saying you
know a straight switch there from
conservative control to labor control
conservatives losing control for the
first time in 20 years exactly the kind
of place labor needs to be making
progress if they're going to have hope
of winning that election well we could
cross now to Stockton and we can talk to
our political correspondent Liz Bates
who has been taking the temperature
there what's going on Liz
or you can hear stocks on teas we're
still getting the results in uh you can
hear those coming out behind me what's
quite interesting here though is that
this is not going with the national
Trend if anything there are 56 seats up
for grabs here A labor defending 22 they
were hoping that they might be able to
take back overall control of this
Council but things have gone in a
completely different direction it is the
conservatives who are gaining seats here
labor just gained one the conservative
party I think have gained around four or
five there's been a lot of boundary
changes to the wards here so it's a bit
difficult to put a number on it at the
moment but this is essentially they were
at a high Watermark last time the
conservative party here and they are
still making games here so this is
completely different from the national
picture and we're going to talk to the
Stockton South MP at Matt Vickers what's
going on here is completely different
from what's going on in the rest of the
country it's well it's exciting it's
positive for me it's positive for lots
of people in stock and I think people
have looked at what the labor Council
was delivering here in Stockton they've
seen the put the counter stack to buy 38
since 2016. they've seen them not
delivering value for money with those
Services because every conservative
Council across the country keeps keep
the counter-tax load and there's two gun
stacks and delivers better Services
that's what people have voted for today
and they've voted for incredible local
Champions we've got I think we've got
three landlords we've got some veterans
we've got an amazing one of them's your
mum one of them is my mum and she's got
him hey
um but we've done it incredibly well
because we've got great local people who
want to well have shown in the last few
weeks have determined they are to get
elected with the graph that they're
putting they have been a day and night
they've been on those streets and
they're going to do exactly the same and
put exactly the same energy into solving
local problems but the other reason I
think we've done so well here in
Stockton and here on t-sad actually
because I think you can hear some
positive news elsewhere in the TV is
that we've delivered on leveling up
we've got a new diagnostic Hospital come
to Stockton we've got eagleslift train
station side thornaby where we are now
it's just out of town deal you can name
all the things it's got very good naming
of local services and but Matt Vickers
you're also a deputy uh conservative
party chair you must be pretty
disappointed at the national picture
um gives you a reaction to that I think
when you look across the country at some
of the results it is a mixed bag you're
out of government if this is replicated
in a general election we'll see people
make decisions on on local elections
about what's going on in their locality
people make decisions because we've been
in government for a very long time this
is not some brand new cycle that a party
that's been in government for 13 years
and they're very disappointed at your
performance in government I think it's
fair to say I think we've when you look
at the polling things are changing well
we had a rough summer that's you know we
did things went rocking it mildly
actually we've now got a very steady
sensible uh enthusiastic energy a
fantastic prime minister and those
Paul's a science term but you know what
people want they want delivery he's
given the five pledges let's see if we
can deliver them whether that be taking
well whether that be increasing growth
whether that be reducing the debt
whether that be cutting the waiting
lists
um stopping those but he's delivering on
those so you say does that just need a
bit more time is that what you're saying
is this a bit of an overhang from the
kind of Liz trust boy shots and disaster
he's given five pleches he's told the
public what he's going to deliver the
public when I speak to them see those as
the priorities he's now got a bit time
to deliver on those we're already seeing
movement on lots of those measures and
we need to get the job done people want
action not words and at the next general
election we'll see we've achieved that
and we'll see the public one put us back
in office
well Matt because well done on the
ground here tonight one of the only
conservative success stories at the
moment thank you very much for speaking
to us
um so that was Matt Vickers there the
Stockton South MP this is really the
only area of the country I think it's
fair to say such aunties where the
conservatives say this it can genuinely
say they are doing quite well here they
made in Rhodes last time in 2019 they're
continuing to build on that more results
to come labor party I think is fair to
say pretty down in the dumps here if
it's replicated across the region and we
have seen other results coming in and
we'll see more of that today that could
be an area of concern for kirst armor is
he not as popular and his party not as
popular in the Northeast as they are in
the rest of the country something to
think about but we'll bring you more
results as they come in interesting so
thanks very much for the update Liz
Bates there in Stockton and now one more
result to bring you this is East
Cambridgeshire which is a conservative
hold and there's been no change in seats
in East Cambridge here the conservatives
have still got 15 and the lib Downs have
still got 13 but the reason I just
wanted to bring it to you despite the
lack of change is because the lib duns
were hoping for change they were looking
for a bit of sign of progress in
cambridges an area with a lot of
demographic change lots of young people
moving towards the area so I think the
live dance would probably be a little
bit disappointed with that result Beth
yeah they will be I mean um they were
talking up um taking seats in East
Cambridge here that was somewhere where
the lib Dems wanted to make gains but
they are also talking about uh whether
they can make gains uh in in Surrey and
Hertfordshire uh also I'm told now you
know I was telling you earlier about
Stratford upon Avon uh the lib Dems are
now calling that they've put out a
statement saying that they believe they
have taken uh that Council and they've
said uh Nadeem Sahar we now face as a
Shakespearean tragedy in his own
backyard see what they did there there's
the liberal Democrats are set to take
overall control of this Council area
Stratford on Avon this incredible result
for the lib damn show just how Fed Up
voters are with the endless stream of
conservative sleaze and Scandals so this
is they've taken Stratford on uh Avon
it's a large rural District covering
most Southern Warwickshire at Nadeem
sahawi we know all the hot water he got
into over his tax Affairs forcing him to
resolve well actually didn't resign he
got sacked as conservative party chair
so that's another big scalp for the lib
Dems there um and and you know
uncomfortable person Nadim Sahari but as
Liam Fox was saying to us earlier there
was a particular local campaign there
run very hard against uh Nadine zahari
as the local MP rather than the
conservative Council as per se yeah
always difficult to read too much into
local results so many different issues
under the Bonnet labor holding on to at
North tyneside they're also holding on
to calderdale at no real change in the
seats uh there well the one person who
really is on top of the numbers for us
today is Ed Conway he's at the big
screen he's crunching through all the
data walking in telez yeah I don't know
if I know everything really on this it's
actually I mean it's quite a fast
evolving story but it's worth just kind
of taking a step back and looking where
we are I've got a few different ways we
can kind of see the big picture here
obviously this is the the kind of
departure Board of different councils
the results that we've had so far
through and you can see that there's
still a lot that we have yet to know
about what's happening uh in this
election but if we look at what we do
know so far and just look at the seats
so Council seats that have been decided
so far it's a pretty clear picture isn't
it look the labor party there and what
you're seeing beneath these big numbers
which is just each of these is the
number of seats that they have so far
won uh in these elections and on this
side you have anywhere that has gained
so the labor party have gained a lot and
they have lost few the conservative
party you can see so have been some
positive stories so they've gained two
but then set that against the fact that
they have lost 250 as well lib dem's
there again gaining more than they are
losing despite the fact that last time
around 2019 they did really quite well
the lip Dems and same thing to the green
party and then you've got others as well
so independent candidates as well but
another way of looking kind of more or
less at the same thing is just by
looking at the change in the share of
the vote that we've seen since 2019 why
do I say since 2019 that was the last
time that these seats were being
contested and these councils and here's
the big change and remember 2019 not a
good time for labor party not good for
the Tories either it was kind of
pre-brexit Theresa May there and Jeremy
corbyn for the labor party but the labor
party have done very well indeed in
terms of increasing their share of the
vote the lib Dems it may look like they
have done kind of not very well but
actually remember they did really well
in 2019 so in a sense they're kind of
cementing some of the seats they got and
some of the results they got there and
on that front it's worth looking at
South gloucestershire because here south
gloucestershire look at the numbers here
conservatives losing control of South
gloucestershire
um down to 23 councilors there the
liberal Democrats up to 20 and labor
party as well getting up into that kind
of number as well so getting up to 17
too and what you see if you kind of look
at the Trends in those votes in places
like South gloucestershire here you can
see just how the conservative vote which
was strong throughout most of the 2000s
has just started to started to fall and
you can see the labor party is starting
to go up as well there and the lib dams
kind of as I say it did very well last
time around but cementing some of their
votes and here's one other way we're
going to be looking at this giving you a
sense of just how well the Tories are
doing and indeed the labor party versus
expectations okay this is kind of
speedometer is one way of looking at it
showing what would constitute a good
night or indeed a bad night for the
conservative party and here you can see
this line this kind of uh dial is
showing where we are right now so the
arrow is where we are right now and
anything here is the loss of seats
across uh England in these elections
anything going that way would be kind of
good for them or the gains as we say
here without looking unlikely but right
now the Tory party that needle going
down down down down down at the moment
it's in areas where they might well
think that it's not too bad but remember
we've only had about a quarter of these
seats declared so far and they're
already very far down compared with
where they would like to be and
according to Michael Thrasher and many
other people looking at these numbers it
might well be that they end up around
this part so down maybe as much as a
thousand maybe more than a thousand
which would be well it says it there
it's very bad bad very bad and we will
update that this kind of speedometer
negative speed in case of the Tory party
over the course of the day and the same
thing again for the labor party as well
so how are they doing versus
expectations uh again for them it's
about raising it so it's about going
above zero and at the moment of course
they are in what you might call kind of
very about territory but this is all
about what happens at the end of the
night so this needle will potentially
move and move and move and move and move
and some people thinking that labor
party might wound up and end up here but
we'll have to wait and see because over
the course of the counting these lines
are going to go up the arrow is going to
go through the dial is going to change
and we're going to find out more of the
sense of what the Electoral landscape in
the UK and specifically in these
elections in England is looking like but
so far this needle is still moving kirst
armor is going into better territory
conservatives are going into worse
territory but things are certainly
changing and evolving so
thanks very much uh Ed well as Ed was
talking we've had another Council result
come through and it is Canik chase the
conservatives have lost control of Canik
chase that is now under no overall
control we can have a look there at the
change in seat numbers they've dropped
four seats the conservative party labor
picking up five looks like they've
picked up seats potentially from the
live Dems as well and the greens are one
as well so that means that the
conservatives have lost control of a
cannock Chase Beth yeah and I'm just
looking up cannock Chase because it's
one of these seats that again it's a key
battle uh ground seat so the
conservatives have held that
parliamentary seat since 2010 it's
actually Amanda Millen who's uh the MP
there she's another former party chair
and a close Ally actually of Boris
Johnson and that suit was created for
the 1997 election that year labor won
cannock Chase can you see what's going
on here so in the Blair years it went uh
labor 2010 went Tori has stayed there
since then uh uh now into no overall
control so that's another another really
interesting one
um the conservatives had seven seats
labor had four
um the greens three lib Dems one and now
uh the labor the conservatives has lost
uh that Council gone to no overall
control I don't know where we've got the
figures but it seems they're losing
quite a lot of councils now to to know
overall control I can't see it on there
but yeah I think they're down 15
councils over 15 conservatives it's
really starting to notch up they're down
232 at Council Saints as well and and
also so if you're just some key like in
Key Battlegrounds straight switches
which is what Michael was talking about
so in Swindon a straight switch to label
though we haven't got that confirmed yet
you know Medway is straight switch to
labor each staff's a straight switch to
labor and that's interesting because
often if there's just a few seats up for
contention it's hard to see a swing
either way because even if you do well
you can't take control or it falls into
no overall control but on these cool
Battlegrounds there's been some straight
switches which label will be pleased
about yeah certainly and it does really
feel as Beth was saying the story kind
of consolidating throughout the day at
the good performance by the labor party
but more than that I guess the concepts
really losing seats to both the liberal
Democrats but also the labor party as
well a difficult day for Russia Cena
let's go to Sam Washington uh shall we
who is going to bring you up to speed
with the rest of the day's news
thank you Sophie at least eight people
have been killed 14 of them injured in a
drive-by-style shooting in Serbia now
it's the second in 48 hours police have
arrested a suspect after an all-night
Manhunt well let's speak to our
correspondent Malena vaselinovich Milena
Serbian people reeling from two episodes
of gun violence and tragedy in very
short order
indeed a second mass shooting in as many
days this is not something that usually
happens in this country the 21 year old
suspect was apprehended after a third by
no less than 600 police officers
overnight in what is quite a rural
forested area about an hour's drive from
the capital Belgrade now the president
of the country Alexander vutic has
called what he did an act of Terror and
he said that it was an attack on all of
Serbia now just to remind the viewers
eight people have been killed including
a 15 year old child as well as 14 people
injured and we've had an update from the
Ministry of Health saying that those 14
people are still in a critical and
life-threatening condition now the
President also vowed the harshest
punishment for the perpetrator of this
ad saying that he will never see the
light of day again meaning that he will
never leave the prison that is of course
for the Judiciary to decide however I
think it's speaks to the strength of
feeling in Serbia about what happened
last night and also what happened on
Wednesday when a 13 year old boy killed
eight of his classmates and a security
guard in a school in Belgrade now take a
listen to what uh President Alexander
vortic had to say
this new Mass criminal attack after an
attack on our children targeted randomly
anyone who happened to be outside a
hunter's Hut around a campfire or
outside their gate going about their
business this is an attack on our whole
country and each citizen feels it
but there are plenty of legal and
illegal weapons in Serbia left over from
the book was of the 1990s however the
gun laws are very strict it's not a big
gun culture in fact the news that there
is such high gun ownership in the
country came as a bit of a surprise to
many citizens in Serbia because a
shooting of this kind is something that
is unheard of in the country the
president has vowed to tighten the
already strict gun laws even more in his
words to entirely disarm Serbia he said
introducing very high fines for those
who may Harbor illegal weapons but these
two events have really a sent off a wave
of soul-searching among the nation as to
why this happened how it could happen
and what can be done to make sure that
these kind of tragedies don't happen
ever again
all right Melina thank you very much
indeed
well it is a hive of activity in central
London as you might expect ahead of the
all-important uh coronation weekend
Let's cross straight over to the mall
now and see what's going on down there
these are live pictures you can see A
procession of Royal cars leaving King
Charles has been hosting a lunch called
the realm of the governor's General and
prime minister's lunch there with many
of the Commonwealth leaders and the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak in attendance
as well Prince William and Princess
Catherine so this is the Royal
procession of cars that has left
Buckingham Palace and we can see that
looks like King Charles getting out of
his car there and doing a walkabout on
the mouth some of the people there of
course been waiting for not just hours
but days ahead of the coronation just to
get a glimpse of the historical event
and perhaps even to get a glimpse of the
people you can see on your screen now
Prince William Princess Catherine there
and indeed King Charles let's have a
listen
[Music]
you're very welcome guys have a lovely
weekend
thank you very much
I hope you're very excited for it
congratulations
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
stop it
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
because there's no one here
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love you very much
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we love King Charles in America
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much
yes thank you so much
[Music]
thank you very much
have a great day
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
leaving
[Music]
that's fine yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
as well so it's nice to be out with
anything hello to everyone who's
obviously doubt for so long and yeah we
do you know overnight some people are
staying overnight overnight yeah
we're here every day yeah so it's going
to be a long time are you tired a bit
yeah
it is I know it's ready
start tomorrow yes but I think everyone
has
enjoy tomorrow
[Music]
good job
[Applause]
guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations congratulations
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you excited for tomorrow
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
the way then
and there we had a walkabout there in on
the mall just outside Buckingham Palace
from his majesty King Charles he was
accompanied there on that Walkabout by
Prince William and his wife Kate uh the
three of them taking their time as they
walked up the mall we were just a meter
away from them as they came up the mouth
they're shaking hands of the people
who've been waiting some of them since
last night
to meet the Royals and to be here for
the big day tomorrow as you can hear
we're in the middle of the crowd at the
moment uh in fact you can't see me
because I cannot get in front of my
camera so we're right in the in the
front row here at the beginning at the
the front of the crowds people pushing
past us it was quite extraordinary what
was a very polite and spaced out uh
crowd suddenly surged forwards as the
members of the royal family came across
to shake hands and meet members of the
public who have been here some of them
as I say uh four a day we're seeing them
now getting back into their cars making
their way into Clarence house after this
walk around so as I say they're they're
Prince Prince William Princess Kate and
His Majesty King Charles there walking
around the crowds waving them off as
they return in fact to Buckingham Palace
returning back in their cars to
Buckingham Palace there and the the
feeling here in the crowd suddenly
explosive going from what was a very
sedate quiet uh crowd to a very
excitable and and it well throng I'm not
sure if you can see me uh now but
obviously those those members of the
royal family who were just shaking hands
with members of the public had come from
a lunch a Commonwealth Governor's lunch
they'd had one final rehearsal in
Westminster Abbey this morning before
coming on this walk around so we're
going to try and make a little bit more
space as people Retreat now but some of
the people who have arrived here will be
camping out now for the night hoping
that the weather will say like this in
order for them to be able to get a
little bit of sleep overnight in a
second I've got to try and get us to
talk to some of those who were lucky
enough to speak to the members of the
royal family but right now just going to
try and make a a little bit of space for
ourselves as I could as you could this
really gives you an idea there we go
sorry Martin our cameraman's stepping
across oh goodness and ladies these are
the ladies I've been speaking to this
morning
these ladies this was their camp this
was their Camp they had set up a rather
beautiful uh well a rather beautiful
bunting to separate their Camp from uh
from the rest I'm so sorry ladies that's
the excitement right for a royal
Walkabout how how was that such
excitement I never had that happen
before we were in the right spot at the
right time they were wonderful how much
time they spent talking to different
people and asking where they'd come from
and you know it's the best state of my
entire life I cannot tell you how
excited I am Carol Carol from Minnesota
for both of you Stacey and Carol from
Minnesota all the way oh look at our our
young friends as well coming down to see
and you I saw you letting them through
to get to the front which was absolutely
lovely there is what's amazing I
overheard I think Leslie uh saying
earlier it's good to share and I feel
like that is the sentiment that's really
sorry it was it was it was Susie and it
really feels as though that is the
sentiment that's been that's been on
show The Best of British yeah absolutely
it's wonderful we've seen across Nations
across across camps I'm actually going
to try and step across the camp here
myself I'm just going to shift this this
chair here so I can get a little bit
more space but we've seen this sharing
of food sharing this food of snacks
everyone here with this sort of teams
but it's a little bit like a festival
isn't it
the atmosphere and the people here is
what makes it and it's what makes
Britain and Charles is going to be a
fantastic kid well it's what makes
Britain but as for our American friends
who've come all the way from uh from
Minnesota Carol I saw you close to tears
yes I was this is absolutely wonderful
to see everybody coming together from
different cultures and different parts
of the world and to look at something
that's been going on since 1056 it's
just absolutely amazing 1066 and this
and there's for you as well this was
this the first time you'd met and spoken
to a role a member of the royal family
no I met William I'm not William I met
some of the other Charles I met Charles
back at the 50th and I told him that I
brought greetings from the colonies
spoons oh he laughed
but I mean what was wonderful there and
I don't know if you felt that was that
they really spent time with each of you
because actually I I also saw you Stacy
talking two two both of them I got a
nice conversation with both of them I
told them it was the most fantastic day
of my life I just need to let you know
that when Diana passed away in 1997 it
was
the one thing in my whole world that I
was so upset that I never got the chance
to meet her and I said then that there
was no way in the world that I was not
going to meet William one day I don't
know when I don't know where I don't
know how but it will happen and people
laughed at me and I'm like no I'm
serious it will and today was that day
and I can't tell you how happy I am did
you tell him that I did I did I told him
it was the happiest most proud day of my
life what what does the royal family
mean to which well let's start with our
American American friends what does it
mean to you because you're not British
what does this mean to you all of this
pop Arts my heart is British it means
it means everything to me ever since I
was a little child I it was the British
royal family that I
I glommed onto it was it was who I
followed it was the glamor of it all it
was knowing that princes and princesses
were real people and not just a Disney
Fantasy it's it's real it's real it's
amazing for me it is the reality of a
long history in the monarchy and the
stability particularly that the queen
brought and she's passed that on to her
son and he will be a good King and he
will bring this stability to the people
too that's that's very interesting and
Jane you are the generation below your
mother and Aunt there do you agree with
that do you think this new king will
continue the work of his mother
yes I think so I mean already he's been
doing amazing works and you know with
the princess trust and in terms of
climate change and although he's had to
set aside some of those passion projects
for the for the bigger picture
um this is what he's been training for
his whole life and I'm sure even though
he's been waiting on his life it's still
going to be scary and daunting but I'm
sure he's I'm sure he's up for it could
you ever have imagined if we you know
rewound you to sort of seven o'clock
this morning when you arrived here that
you would have been shaking hands with
Bridge William Princess Kate
and I looked at each other and I said a
royal Walkabout I think there's only one
reason they could take down one of the
rows I'm like this oh my God it's my
time my time has come
absolutely wonderful I think I also
overheard as a couple of spots of rain
start right now I think I overheard a
conversation just earlier uh with a call
to Robert Dyas perhaps for for tonight
what are your Provisions for tonight
because your your Camp has been
completely destroyed what are you gonna
do tonight
we'll get something together we've got
some mum and I we've got some Bibby bags
you know some of those emergency
sleeping bag type Affairs and um we've
made a call to my husband to maybe get
some top Hall in
um although he was a bit dubious about
it and he swore it was not going to rain
tonight I hope you won't take this the
wrong way but you don't look like the
type of people who camp out regularly
you look far too glamorous so are you
gonna be okay in your baby bags and on
your seat so you're gonna get any sleep
at all
I'm not sure about the Sleep elements
but you know help is only a phone call
away we met we met two Americans here
earlier on who said they were going
shopping in Bond Street for tents so I
said they must be go places
they need to find a hardware store
others are are available oh well ladies
it's been an absolute pleasure to talk
to you thank you so much and I'm so glad
that you did get uh your chance to meet
royalty uh to our friends that hear from
both sides of the Atlantic have been
camping out since this morning we've met
others along this row uh who've been
camping out since last night there is of
course another night to go uh before the
coronation but from the mall uh for now
thanks
absolutely wonderful stuff uh Bell and
Auntie there speaking to people who were
trying to meet at the Royal Family ahead
of the coronation this weekend a little
bit of breaking news to bring you now
when it comes to covid-19 because the
World Health Organization has been
meeting today and they have decided to
downgrade covid from a pandemic to an
endemic and that effectively means that
it's no longer considered a global
Health Emergency so a real Milestone
there for the covid-19 pandemic which of
course killed at least seven million
people worldwide just to bring you a
statement from the director General he
said it's with great hope that I declare
covid-19 over as a global Health
Emergency he did go on to say that does
not mean that covid-19 is over as a
global Health threat I have to say uh
given the last few years I'm sure you
watching and also for us as well it does
feel like a real moment that covid-19
being downgraded no longer seen as a
global Health Emergency
well let's pretend shall we to the
results of the local elections that are
now coming in thick and fast I just want
to start off with the state of the
parties just to show exactly where we
are now when it comes to the state of
the parties uh labor are up at six
councils the conservatives down 18 so a
very difficult day so far for Rishi
sunac the lib Dems are up three and
let's just focus on the lib Dems a
little bit more because we've had a
couple of councils declaring uh just
while we had that at Walkabout on the
Mal uh Stratford upon Avon first that
has gone to the lib Dems they've gained
that directly from the conservatives you
can see look at the seats there the live
dams have gained 15 seats and the
conservatives down 14. another similar
story as well in decorum two which is in
Hertfordshire at the lib Dems gaining at
that from the conservative party it was
a big Target for the lib Dems they've
gained that from the conservative party
and those are two of the three direct
switches of councils that have gone from
the conservatives to being controlled by
the lib Dems at the other is winset in
Berkshire let's bring Beth rear now
signs the blue wall looking vulnerable
and actually
um I didn't remember this but someone
did send it to me that decorum was the
location where at the launch of the lib
demp campaign you might remember it how
could we forget really Ed David bursting
through the bales of hay that have been
painted blue to demonstrate on a on a
combine harvest store is that I don't
think it was to demonstrate that you
know the breakdown and I'm I'm sort of
joking a bit because do you remember
actually another image jumps to mine
which was Boris Johnson doing exactly
the same thing about you know breaking
the get BR get brexit done breaking
through the wall do you remember that I
did back in the 2019 election so Ed
David kind of Apes this but actually
um he's having the last laugh at the
moment isn't he because he is picking up
seats
um very strongly in these blue all areas
these are the rural parts of of the
South the Tory shires the heartlands and
yeah decorum a lib damn game from the
conservatives the first time in 20 years
they've won a majority there
um and it is home to two parliamentary
seats which are conservative they've
also taken
um Stratford upon Avon 15 gains there
from Tories losing 14 seats as you said
straight switches in Windsor decorum and
Stratford so for the lib Dems and I
can't remember what seats are they're on
about plus 60 now I think are they uh
they haven't got exact figures here
their past three they're on plus 79 plus
I mean that is actually your blink
Sophie and they're up 20 seats
you know they're up to 80s you know
nearly 80 seats now the labor up 150 the
conservatives down 116. like if you
stand back and go what's going on here I
mean you know as I was saying earlier
back in 2019 before Theresa May lost her
job and there was the brexit election
and Boris Johnson won that astonishing
victory in the polls
um it was a plague on both houses in
that set of local elections which is the
direct comparison to this because the
Tories lost loads of seas and labor who
really should have been making gains
also lost seats I mean far less but I
mean it was a terrible night this is a
plague on the house of the conservatives
in that every single part labor lib
don't screen others apart from others
actually just dropped four but the the
other parties are all gaining uh where
the conservatives are losing and you
know when I spoke to labor lib Democrats
they would say to me people are really
fed up and they want to punish the
conservatives and the conservatives will
review that it's not going to be pretty
but you know rishi's stabilizing our our
ship the new prime minister and now it
looks like you know that that punishment
at the polls is really beginning to play
out and as you said the the bigger
question is what's the reader cross for
a general election
and on these results as Michael thrush
was saying
um in terms of the projected vote share
laborer eight points ahead of the
conservatives uh that would make them
the largest party throw in Scotland as
Michael thrush was saying You could
argue as the labor suspenders have been
telling us overnight
um that they could be on course for an
outright majority so I mean kirstma
um has his his lines to take that as
Michael thrash was saying if you were
conservative you might be saying
minority government do you want lib Dems
in control or SMP sharing power so
they've got a line of attack too but
it's fascinating how these local
elections extrapolate out into National
pitch and of course their local
elections people do vote on different
issues but they're also the first
massive test at The Ballot Box of of
sunac and also this red wall I'm sorry
this blue wall Battleground with the lib
Dems conservatives which is is working
for the lib damage but certainly hearts
in the Tories yeah as you say as Beth
was saying there at that image of Ed
Davey breaking through the blue Hale
barrels I don't guess it does sum up
really a lot of the night air thank you
very much indeed Beth well let's get
some reaction to the local election
results and in particular to the
performance of the conservative party
Ben Bradley is a conservative MP for
Mansfield and the leader of
Nottinghamshire County Council cut the
spin this is a really really bad set of
results for you
hi Sophie um it's certainly a
challenging night right and um although
you expect the party of government to
lose seats during a kind of midterm
election like this it's clearly really
challenging I think the Prime Minister
was right to say this morning that what
it shows is you know he's not been there
very long he's talked about things he
wants to achieve people expect him to
deliver outcomes he's got some time to
do that before a general election but
there are also some positive spots here
in Mansfield we've gone from uh coming
fourth in the last set of Elections to
second I think and we're going to gain
some seats here so there's some good
news as well
I mean that you know you might be able
to cling to a few seats here and there
is good news but look let's get real you
know the story of the night whether it
is in the South losing to the live Dems
Council switching straight from the
conservative to live Dome control or in
other parts of the country in Medway or
Stoke where councils are switching to
labor I mean this is a really difficult
set of results and the one message that
does seem to be consistent is people
really are not that happy with the
conservatives right now
well I think you know we know that we've
been through really difficult times both
in terms of the politics of the Autumn
that's just gone and also the economy
right one of the biggest tests of uh
election
um and how people will vote in elections
is you know do I feel better off and
certainly at the minute things are
challenging economically but the Prime
Minister has laid out his priorities for
the next year there's a year 18 months
for him to uh deliver on those and I do
think he's picked the right things you
know ultimately what I've heard on the
doorsteps in recent weeks is to a
certain extent you know everybody talks
and nothing ever happens in politics
well he's got 18 months to deliver on
those things and if he does so I think
we'll be okay but if you look at the
swings around the country certainly
across England I don't think that the
the swing to Labor uh this uh the last
couple of days uh is enough to get them
a majority in Westminster I don't think
it is it's big enough it's certainly not
a 97 Blair kind of situation you know
they've made
um marginal gains it's one of them a lot
of seats but the actual swing across the
country is not massive
as we were talking to seeing the
conservatives losing North Warwickshire
to no overall control so another
ancillary there lost by the
conservatives
I mean look this is the first electoral
test for Rishi student Excellence who
became prime minister Boris Johnson left
office when the polls were in a much
healthier position than this do you
think that actually that was a mistake
but I certainly think that the Autumn of
um leadership contests and
um chaos to a certain extent has not
helped and that it should be planning
obvious really but Rishi is certainly
studied the ship from that perspective
as I say lots of people in my part of
the world were very pro-boris uh and
I've heard over recent months people
being increasingly impressed with the
Prime Minister we've got a kind of
unique situation here because we've got
really strong independent party that
makes it much more complicated electoral
situation they've been wiped out today
in the conservative party will make
gains so you know it is a mixed picture
I just think that the shift from
conservative to labor here is two and a
half percent right in a seat that is a
16 000 conservative majority uh in the
Parliamentary elections that is not
enough for them to to win back Mansfield
in the next election and they're going
to have to show much better figures than
that if they want to win an overall
majority
you say that though and actually I agree
that Professor Thrasher says the results
so far point to a labor minority
government rather than a majority
government but the first point to make
is either way the conservatives are
being turfed out but secondly if you
look at Scotland it could be that labor
are in course for a majority that surely
the complacency that we see in some of
the responses from the conservatives so
far that's a bit of a slap in the face
debaters I don't think there's any
complacency we've all been out on the
doorsteps in recent weeks we all
understand the frustrations that people
have with all sorts of issues and often
the issues that Rishi himself has picked
out people do talk to me about small
boats people do talk to me about the
Health Service in particular and that
the cost of living is a real challenge
they're the prime minister's
capabilities he's got 12 18 months to
deliver on those priorities that's the
commitment that he's made actually told
if he does that I think we'll be all
right if he doesn't clearly the post
today show that that's going to be
challenging but there's time for him to
do that and I think we've got the right
priorities I haven't heard anything in
the doorsteps in recent days that I
wouldn't expect given the way things
have been over the last 26 to nine
months so there's time for us to rectify
that Scotland's a massive unknown isn't
it but we don't know what the SMP
situation is going to be we don't know
who's going to benefit from that really
yes
um but actually the polls across England
don't show at the minute that they've
done enough to win that
whatever happens over the next year 18
months whatever the results are is where
she seem like going to lead you into the
next election
100 uh there is absolutely no sense uh
in US uh Naval gazing at this point we
uh have a clear plan of accident we have
um those issues Five Points on the
economy on uh Health Service on small
boats that we need to tackle I think
those things are broadly universally uh
agreed certainly across um sectors of
the population that would consider
voting conservative they're the right
things to prioritize he's got time to
deliver on those things and he's made a
start on those things but we do have to
deliver there should be no complacency
that if we don't manage to make inroads
into those issues we will find it really
difficult colleagues unfortunately uh
local councilors paying the price for
that and that always is really difficult
as a counselor myself to see really good
counselors losing their seats because of
national policies that's always
frustrating but again you know it's not
across the board here in Mansfield we've
gone from fourth to second we're making
games uh Bassett lodges next door the
same so there are spots around the
country where we're still making good
progress okay thank you very much uh
indeed uh good to talk to you Ben
Bradley there saying that no matter what
happens but she's seen like it's 100
going to be leading the party into the
next election we've got Ed Conway
standing by but I could just see
Darlington uh remaining under no overall
control well let's go to Ed before we
bring you that results show you what we
learned so far red
yeah I mean it's interesting isn't it
kind of results actually coming in thick
and fast at the moment so darlington's
you're saying uh we're getting new
numbers coming through at the moment as
well it's worth just kind of taking a
step back as well and kind of looking at
the big picture here and when we look at
the big picture you know this these are
the numbers uh these are the different
councils that are being contested of
course it is England we're talking about
here councils in England and you're
seeing the color this makeup of the
geography the political geography of
local government in England starting to
change and I'm going to show you some
ways in which that's changing that
really kind of underline it but one way
of just kind of looking at what was
happening right now and what's happening
right now is a redrawing of the map uh
is to look at these bars here they are
giving you a sense of what's Happening
beneath the surface when you look at
counselors across each of these
different areas so 230 different
councils about over 8 000 seats so 8 000
councilors and everything's changing
labor is doing much better so gaining
198 losing 32 the conservatives look at
the conservatives gaining 24 so it's not
all about losses but they're look over
here
317 that bar going down into negative
territory and extraordinary net loss for
the Tory party lib Dems gaining 107 so
lib dem's having another good good night
as well good elections green party as
well so up by 55 for the green party too
but this is pretty clear here the
conservatives not having a very good
time when you look not just at the kind
of at the colors of different uh the
names of the different councils but at
the map across England you can see just
how much that's changing we still have a
lot of kind of light gray areas so areas
where we have yet to have the results
and you see that here look only 230 202
sorry 2
636 uh seats that we have so far out of
8 000. but when you look at some of the
areas that we're hearing about whether
it's Plymouth there uh in the South uh
West whether it's areas like there's
there's Windsor and maidenhead that's
gone lib Dems as well hasn't it and up
here in the Midlands it's going to be
kind of interesting as well because that
story that we had recently about areas
which typically when it was the kind of
Blair area when it was new labor were
relatively comfortably labor but then
swung across to the conservative party
party areas like for instance cannock
Chase well up until now this was
conserved it was conservative controlled
but they've lost it they've lost control
of it and when you look at the lines in
terms of this is just showing you going
back to the 90s the lines of who was in
control here it was the labor party in
the 1990s then the conservatives started
to kind of get back around the 2000s and
gain control gradually recently but now
this is what we're seeing here look at
that red line starting to go up so labor
regaining some influence here and
knocking the Tories out of control of
cannock Chase and that's just one of the
many councils where they are defending
okay and here you have a a kind of board
of the areas where the Tory party are
defending these councils uh there's
cannock Chase gone to no overall control
we've arranged this it's another way of
looking at the same thing we've arranged
it by the kind of marginal swing you
need for the Tories to potentially lose
control of these different councils from
areas where are relatively safe through
to areas where you need a bigger swing
for them to lose it but the Striking
thing is
oh let's take a step back these were all
blue at the start of the counting these
were all conservative councils this
entire board was painted blue and now
just look at it look how much of it is
gray dark gray no overall control look
how much his orange for lip dance yellow
for lip dance look how much is turning
red as well so East Staffordshire there
but there have been others that have
been further bigger swings to get to
labor party and you're seeing now here
the scale of just how difficult how
tough it has been for the Tory party and
remember as I say we are still only
maybe a quarter getting towards a third
of the way through of the counting and
so far the news has been almost entirely
negative for the conservative party good
for labor good for the lib Dems how good
we'll have to wait and see but really
terrible for wish you soon act so far
yeah that really does bring it home ed
Conway thank you very much indeed for
your analysis
couple of results to bring you now I
just want to take you to Darlington uh
first in the T side a really critical
part of the country when it comes to
elections and Darlington despite a very
closely and fiercely fought campaign on
both sides remains under no overall
control labor are up five seats but that
is not enough to take control of the
council the conservatives are down eight
look at that the green party up five so
perhaps it was the greens who actually
stopped at Labor getting the control
that they wanted
um it is a key Target for labor the kind
of town that could decide the general
election really a bit of a poster boy if
you like for the sort of Red Bull wall
seats
um in the Northeast Angela Rayners
visited Richard visited he had that
picture of inspecting a pothole I think
in Darlington well you know you're in
local election territory then when the
prime minister is peering at portholes
uh Beth yeah you know I was up I was up
in this part of the world last week
those key seats there and it was Labor
didn't know if they were going to take
councils but they did need to make
inroads and they will be with Darlington
I think they'll be quite disappointed
they haven't taken it but also the fact
the Prime Minister was there examining
potholes which has been filled in that
pothole no in all senses I mean it has
been fiercely contested you've got to
remember Ben Hutchins up there as well
he's the local mayor and he has quite a
strong local following so this is a
really big Battleground
um you know we went up there because we
were looking at tease Valley and we went
to uh stopped and to see if labor could
they'd need to take five seats or they
they need to yeah get five seats off the
Tories could they could they do it but
that would be disappointing to them but
we've got another one that they will be
happy about and that's error wash now
they've taken out I'm just sorry I'm
just trying to find my stats
somewhere here
um this we like drowning in paper and
computer screens
um so labor with we haven't got this
confirmed yet but labor tell us that
they've taken error wash now this is a
Tory held Council since 2003 so it would
be another straight swap in the local
elections of 2019 the conservatives had
27 seats labor 19 libdums won and it's
interesting in Westminster terms as well
because it has a huge Tory majority it's
Maggie through seat uh 10
606 Tory majority in 2019 and guess who
held it between 1997 to 2010. labor so
it's again one of those spellweather
seats if you like that you know held
during the Blair years for labor turned
Tory uh labor have taken that Council
um and you know what I'm picking up from
you know amid all the spin from some of
the um
labor strategist I'm just what they are
arguing to me is that um what the
results are showing are bigger swings
and key Battlegrounds to the next
elections that's how they're arguing it
and they're saying that what they're
trying to do is get their very more
efficiently spread across the country so
that they can win majorities where they
need to win seeds so you're going to
hear a lot more of that and
and in a way it makes sense as to why
they campaigned in these key
Battlegrounds be it Medway or Swindon
because then they can make the segment
about that they'd have genuine momentum
not just become the biggest party but to
actually win the Battlegrounds
um so I think we're gonna as the as the
day and night unfolds I think we're
going to be hearing a lot more of that
argument yeah really uh important stuff
when it comes to reading across the
general election and a bit of a tip from
Beth there if you want to put whole
field in get the PMT be pictured with it
um thanks very much for all the analysis
um let's take a bit of stock now at
shall we with how the main parties have
done so far we are joined here in the
studio by Harry Burns he's a former
labor party election organizer and now
political consultant thanks very much
for being with us so how early we're
going to be looking at these results
then well I think to Beth's Point um
labor warranty talk about how targeting
has worked and in any election campaign
when you have limited resources money
people time and visits from prominent
politicians you have to focus them in
the places where you know you can
achieve the the greatest return for your
investment and that
whether or not kirstan was claim that
they're on calls for a majority is
actually true it feels like at the
minute the numbers I mean look they're
just in England right so that does come
with a bit of a health warning points
towards a minority labor government
right well the benefit of not working
for the party anymore is that I can be
slightly Freer with what I say I think
it shows that labor have made huge
strides since 2019 I mean you would have
bitten the hand off anybody that offered
you this result back then
um does it suggest that they're on calls
for a majority possibly they might be
saying things that that I haven't seen
but it does show that they are moving in
the right direction and I mean um for
the lead of the opposition it's only
when you get close to the election that
you get more of a fair Hearing in the um
you know amongst the general population
and so hopefully key will be able to
connect more with voters uh we'll be
able to sell Labor's policy offer when
it comes to the election and we'll be
able to assume you start to shift more
swing voters towards labor and what do
you think he needs to do Kirsten because
there has been criticism it hasn't he
that he hasn't
how much in way of a concrete policy or
his own individual Vision I mean when I
asked labor politicians what the biggest
policy is they say the windfall tax and
I think well is that really enough
well I think at this stage in the game
it's about selling a vision it's about
selling the alternative it's not about
coming up with a costed uh policy
platform because people like use you
know smart people in the media uh I'll
take that we'll come again we'll we'll
start to add up the cost of all the
policies they will start to build the
manifesto sort of in their minds and
they will then go to labor with their
you know this is going to cost x amount
of money how are we going to pay for it
and until you get close to the election
you don't want the economy is going to
look like so you can't come out too
early and also the Tories will Nick the
good ideas they have done and they will
continue to do that if labor come up
with you know anything uh that really
connects with people but too far away
from the general I guess the other
problem that labor have is that people
in the media like myself are going to
start asking about coalitions and doing
deals with other terms what do you think
their answer should be there I mean
absolutely no Coalition uh we saw the
damage that was done by the ambiguity
going into 2015 general election with
the so-called Coalition of chaos which
really did damage to Ed miliband I saw
it in the doorstep when I was out
knocking on doors in 2015 and I think it
really does you know people want they
don't want grubby back room deals you
know they want a party to come to the
electorate with a clear policy offer and
a clear program for government they
don't want people to get together behind
the scenes and deprive people of the
choice in an election well thanks very
much I want to bring you the result from
Swindon if I may because we just got the
full result from Swindon a really really
key Battleground for the parties and
it's a straight switch remember at Labor
gaining control of Swindon from the
conservatives and we can look at the
breakdown labor now have 33 seats on the
council they're up nine and the
conservatives down 10 so they lost nine
seats to labor and one to the liberal
Democrats I mean Beth that is a pretty
difficult result there for the
conservative party
yeah but you know Kirsten I was there he
launched his election campaign for the
locals in Swindon it's a key uh
Battleground it's one of the bellwethers
that will determine who becomes the next
prime minister
um quite frankly if you launch your
campaign then then you don't win the
seat that's
awkward right so I mean I expected them
um to win Swindon but nevertheless as I
was saying in terms of building the
narrative about showing progress towards
winning a general election if you can
take places like Swindon you can take
places like Medway you can build that
argument but you know it's a straight A
straight switch their Tories down 10
labor gaining nine and just to jump in I
can see there at the gray sort of strip
at the bottom of the screen the
conservatives of a lost control of cheek
spree to no overall control as well it
was still run by the conservative they
did suffer heavy losses there in 2019
the lib Dems were hoping to threaten too
but Tewkesbury there being lost by the
conservatives to no overall control
we'll fill that in with the full results
when we have them but we just wanted to
bring it to you as soon as possible I
think we can bring in another guest for
you now at Sarah Southern who's a former
senior aide to David Cameron and I have
to say it feels like whenever we talk to
someone for a couple of minutes there is
another
Council that is lost by the
conservatives it's been a really really
tough day
absolutely you know I think it has been
a very difficult day for the Tories and
I would imagine it will continue to do
so until all of the results are in but
none of it's really that surprising I
think certainly within conservative
circles certainly with what they were
briefing out to the media they were
expecting this difficult set of results
so it's not really a big shot even
though it is obviously quite
disappointing oh come on it is a bit of
a big shock right I mean yes they were
briefing a thousand suits but that was
expectation management wasn't it I mean
that was the lowest end of prediction so
for many of the analysts and they're
only predicting them because of the
pretty catastrophic polling that the
conservatives have seen
I'm not surprised by it um I think you
know if you look at the local elections
we had last year when
um councils like Wandsworth and
Westminster you know absolute Tory
strongholds where council tax was low
and they were lost I kind of felt as
though it was going to be but I'd have
to admit when I see that somewhere like
shoots Breeze lost to novel control it
just made me go oh crumbs it really is
not going to be a good day
yeah do you think that there is any
Landing zone now for the next general
election for the conservatives to remain
in office
well I think this is going to be the big
challenge for Rishi stunnak I think you
know one of the things that's going to
be branded up from today is that these
elections are almost people kind of
voting against the the Johnson and the
truss era and this is why they've voted
against the Tories today by the end of
the day Rishi sunak is the prime
minister he's the one leading the party
so he's the one who's taking the brunt
of this so he obviously hasn't convinced
the voters yet if he has a general
election in May 2024 he's only got 12
months to change people's minds but has
he now got the local support has he got
the member support has he got kind of
the troops on the ground as it were to
deliver his election message and to
maintain the support that he's got
how what will be happening right now in
number 10 you know they'll be pouring
through the results won't they uh
whether it's the Rishi sunak team or
whether it's the conservative campaign
team as well what are they going to be
thinking
a lot of slightly uncomfortable phone
calls from Council leaders who've lost
their seats today I can't imagine
somewhere like Windsor Council will be
having a great day and certainly won't
be having great conversations uh with
cchq and number 10. so I think there'll
be some some slight uncomfortable
conversations happening but I think
they'll also just be chalking up to we
predicted this was going to happen it's
perhaps not as good as we would like but
we've got to just prepare for what's
coming next we've got to prepare for the
general election this has been Rishi
sunak's first electoral test but we've
got to get ready for the really big one
and talking about preparing for the
really big one as you put it what should
they be doing more of the same or do
they actually need to think look what
we're doing isn't working I'm going to
rip this up and do something different
well I think they might have to do that
yeah so uh it's not going to be easy I
would be very intrigued to see kind of
what hires they make in the coming
months to kind of prepare for the
general election
um I'd be interested to see kind of what
big announcements they're going to be
making
um you know as your previous uh speaker
was just saying you know they don't like
the labor doesn't like to put out too
many ideas case the Tories nicked them
so but I think all of the parties are
going to be putting their best foot
forward
um and I would hope that the Tories will
be leading with that okay well thank you
very much so good to talk to you today
well let's have a quick chat shall we uh
before uh we leave you um with Beth um
Beth what's your main sort of takeaways
so far
well look my main my main takeaway is we
kind of it's coming out as we expected
um the downside is for the conservatives
which are putting in which are having a
performance that is worse than they
would have hoped I mean much worse than
they would have hoped you know if we
think that they could have perhaps
written off 500 seat losses as mid-term
Blues I mean if they they could have
maybe contained the losses but you know
we're barely I don't know wouldn't I
mean the third in if that um
in terms of the seats we're barely you
know eating into the 8 000 seats that
are to be declared at some point in the
next uh hours and they're all already on
over 300 of losses labor up 174. the lib
derms up 90 the greens up uh 53 so I
think that there is a there is a clear
uh pencil movement squeeze on the
conservatives where they are being
really battered by the liberal Democrats
in their traditional rural Heartland
some of the remain facing seats actually
swinging away
um from Rishi sunak and then in the red
wall you know that you know labor isn't
having such a huge March but the thing
is labor of picking up other real real
key election Battlegrounds in other
parts of the country and then you know
then the big question is really about
Labor and is Kirsten on course to win a
majority government what they said this
morning and as the day goes on they're
finding more and more reasons to argue
it it's really it's really telling isn't
it Beth you can see the buoyancy and The
Confidence from labor increasing as the
day goes on and the key takeaway is it's
looking harder shall we say for to see a
path for the conservatives winning the
next general election after these
results we'll have more from you from us
I should I say in a few moments
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this has got news coming up today we are
going to be on the mile where crowds
have already gathered ahead of
tomorrow's coronation
and this afternoon they were rewarded
for that earlier tomorrow
and the crowd on the other side of the
street weren't forgotten either as
William and Kate went on a walk about
that
coming up we'll also take a look at the
crown jewels ahead of their starring
role in tomorrow's service
and we'll be hearing from many of the
royal Watchers who've taken up their
positions for the big day
plus we are going to be continuing with
our special coverage of the local
election results
it's been Delight for labor over some
key victories over the conservatives
secure Starman says the party is ready
for power
make no mistake we are on course for a
labor majority at the next general
election
[Applause]
and we should see now commit some
results have been disappointing his
party losing cancels to both labor and
the Liberals
the message I am hearing from people
tonight is that they want us to focus on
their priorities and they want us to
deliver for them and that's about
halving inflation growing the economy
two one
and some strong results for the liberal
Democrats as they call time see what we
did there on the conservatives
also coming up the leader of the Russian
mercenary Wagner group rails at the
Kremlin and threatens to pull his troops
out of Batman next week
and after more than three years the
World Health Organization downgrades the
status of the pandemic
I declare covid-19 over as a global
Health Emergency
[Music]
good afternoon you might be seeing the
local election uh backdrop to me but
we're going to start on the mile where
crowd's been arriving in plenty of time
ahead of the coronation tomorrow and
this afternoon they were treated to a
visit not only from the cane but also
from The Prince and Princess of Wales we
can begin this out with a look back at
the Royal Walkabout
congratulations
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Leave It Low
tomorrow
it's an interesting days
are you guys camping though thank you
we'll be here when you go by tomorrow I
remember when I was in here for my
wedding I can hear you all soon
so I'm sure you'll know
uh more on the coronation as we get it
full coverage with our reporters who
have been following that story and of
course full coverage from 7am tomorrow
as well in the meantime we can go back
to the local elections because it has
been a dramatic day of results uh so far
labor but really making inroads on the
performance of 2019 and the
conservatives losing well just about
everyone to the labor party but also to
the lib Dems too let's have a look now
at the state of the parties because
labor are up 163 seats so taking control
of an extra six councils as well and
look at the conservative person
performance they are nudging 300 seat at
losses 292 seats down and they've also
lost the control of 21 councils the live
dam is good night for them up 95 it
really is quite extraordinary just in
the last few moments we've also seen a
rugby going to nowhere control so a loss
there for the conservative party too at
Middlesbrough I'll actually have a look
at rugby I think the concept of losing
that to no overall control they have
dropped uh two seats the conservatives
gaining two seats as well we've been
getting reaction throughout the day from
the party leaders let's listen to Rishi
Cena it should be said this was pretty
early this morning he has had a pretty
difficult few hours since this interview
with him
we've only had a quarter of the results
in actually we're making progress in key
election Battlegrounds like Peterborough
Bassett Law Sandwell but the message I
am hearing from people tonight is that
they want us to focus on their
priorities and they want us to deliver
for them and that's about halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt cutting waiting lists and stopping
the boats that's what people care about
that's what they want us to deliver and
that's what I and the government are
going to work very hard to do
well he says he's going to have to work
very hard and he certainly will if he is
going to the labor leader Zakir starmer
has said that Labor's on course for a
majority at the next general election
you didn't just get it over the line you
blew the doors off
the first picture here since
1998. an amazing amazing set of results
I didn't doubt it when I saw the energy
and the commitment and the case that we
were making but what a fantastic result
here in Medway and we're having
fantastic results across the country
Plymouth what a night they've had in
and then Stoke
and up to Middlesbrough all the places
that we need to win the Battlegrounds
and make no mistake we are on course for
a labor majority at the next general
election
yeah
that was no surprise that kirstama was
looking pretty happy there but look at
this result it's the first labor loss of
the election because labor have lost
control of Slough Council that's gone to
no overall control you can see the seats
there the conservatives are up 16 seats
and labor are down 18 seats and the
Little Gems are up three I mean that
really is an absolutely extraordinary
result there really I guess going
against the tide of the results we've
seen and let's bring it back well I mean
I I just it's not even on my spreadsheet
of places to watch
um Slough going
um into no overall control but look at
that a straight switch away from labor
into the hands of the conservatives so
one uh bad result for Labor uh today
they have lost the council it's gone to
no overall control and it's their fast
labor loss of hundreds of C seats and
dozens of councils declaring it does
feel extraordinary it's one of those
ones I think is there been a typo
somewhere but no it does that is correct
there have been boundary changes and but
it was certainly thought to be a safe
labor Council that very surprising as
we've been talking you can also see that
at the conservative moving Pendle to no
overall control as well they lost
control in 2019 to get back and now lost
control of Pendle Council as well I mean
that is just one of many I guess for the
conservatives so far we can see it on
our screens now the conservatives are
down three seats in Pendle labor up one
the lib dome's up two and Beth it feels
like that in many ways is the story of
the day where the conservatives are
shedding votes to both labor and the
live Jones well I mean they're shutting
votes to labor the lib Dems to Greens
they're shedding them all around the
country if you were in any doubt that uh
Rishi sunat's conservatives are in real
trouble and we can see see it in the
National polls but what we're now
getting is the actual reality of what
people are doing at The Ballot Box and
you will get conservatives that will
come on onto Sky News today and say it's
local elections you know the lib dams
perform better you know the turnout is
low but equally it gives us an
indication of you know the state of play
the political weather in the country and
when I'd speak to you know rival
politicians and indeed when I've been
around the country you know we did a
focus group in High Wycombe that's in
buckinghamshire near where I grew up
actually you know we went up um to tease
Valley last week to talk to voters there
and wherever you go what I pick up is
that people talk about change it's not
that they necessarily want to fall in
the arms of the labor party but there is
a sense of the country not working for
them and I think it's actually something
that conservative MPS themselves would
admit that people feel feel that the
government haven't been delivering if
you think about what's going on with NHS
waiting lists for example the cost of
living the strikes in which the schools
are closed and the hospitals you know
you see in picket lines outside and the
rail uh rail Services aren't working
very well and you're picking up that
sentiment around the country I guess the
million dollar question and the one that
we will probably spend the next year or
so really chewing over is whether or not
Rishi sunak from this position can begin
to close the gap on labor in order to
try and have a fighting chance for the
next general election and I think what
had happened in the mood music in
Westminster and I think you'll probably
have felt this too Sophie was you know
Rishi soon that came in there was a
five-point plan it was all calm it was
competence and staying beneath the radar
and no flamboyant speeches and and no
chaos and there was a sense of
oh the conservatives are really back in
play and then what we've now have in now
is the kind of that idea the idea that
circle around in this place in
Westminster being tested in the country
I think what we're seeing is actually
the the national polls are beginning to
translate into wins for labor and
critically uh they are winning in
Bellwether seats across the country in
areas that are going to be the
Battlegrounds for the 2024 general
election so labor arguing now we're
eight points ahead
uh once you take into account Scotland
where you know kirstan has been so lucky
that there's been an implosion of the
SMP that they're heading for a majority
and that's what we're going to be
debating I think it's it's really
extraordinary the results come in thick
and fast uh now I can see the bottomless
screens there the lib Dems are gaining
at South Hampshire form the conservative
party also Northeast Derbyshire labor
have gained control of that from no
overall control Northeast Derbyshire
kind of another former coal mining
Center the kind of place where labor did
badly in recent years and signs that
kirst armor is beginning to win some of
those places uh back they're up 10 seats
the conservatives are down 11. it was
increasingly turning into a bit of a
location for Sheffield commuters so
again kind of demographic changes uh
helping there as well the South hands
result there lib Dem gained from the
conservatives as well the label will be
really into mostly established because
that was a key gain and just Pendle
going back to that the Pendle uh
conservative lost to no overall control
we were up in Pendle and we went to a
conservative Club in Pendle and whilst
the people we spoke to uh there were not
fans of uh Kirsten but that is for sure
they were quite Furious uh with the
conservative party I think one of the
sub stories of this whole thing will be
voter not voter apathy but a decision of
Voters not to go to the polls and one
very seasoned conservative campaigner
said to me apathy is a killer for us
because their view is Tony Blair one in
97 in a large part because the
conservative vote didn't turn out to
vote against him so he was neutral
enough that traditional conservative
voters didn't find Tony Blair so
offensive slash worrying slash
intimidating
they didn't they didn't kind of actively
they could kind of live with him being
in number 10 and they were disillusioned
and didn't turn out the vote and and
that is another sub story within all of
this which is is it that conservative
voters it's not that they're switching
to kirstama but they are just staying at
home and and they need that to not
happen into a general election so
somehow Rishi Suna has to find something
to motivate his base to turn out and at
the moment it seems every which way he
looks around the country every single
group of Voters
they're not really very interested in
giving him their support at the moment a
bit of a wake-up call for many in the
conservative party we've been talking an
awful lot about how these votes refer
over to a general election but there is
a bit of a caveat should we say to the
slower result that I want to give you
because this does show right um how
local issues play into it as well that
extraordinary flowers are labor losing
control well Slough was actually one of
three councils given special
dispensation to raise council tax by 10
without a referendum and it then
declared bankruptcy in 2021 so perhaps
on paper a safe seat for labor but a
good example of how in local elections
Dairy specific local factors can come
into play as well as one person will
know Ed Conway who is at the big screen
uh he's been crunching through all the
voting data for us today Ed what have
you been looking at yeah it's a really
good example actually Sophie because
yeah this this is partly something we're
all looking at it aren't we as a
question of what does this say for the
bigger political picture around the UK
but of course these are specific local
election battles about often local
issues local services and so on uh
across not all of England and it's just
I should say England in terms of the UK
it's England it's not the Northern
Ireland it's not Wales uh it's not
Scotland so there's Slough was that was
painted in red before but now that's
gone to their overall control so the
Tories uh the labor rather have lost
control uh of Slough and that obviously
underlines the fact that it's not all
going one way uh for Cirque Dharma
however when you look at the overall
pictures when you look at the number of
councilors numbers of seats across
England here and the change it's not
changed most importantly that we're
talking about so these the in the center
are the overall numbers of seats that
we've had so far and we're kind of about
getting a third of the way through but
the key thing here is looking beneath
the surface so right now labor having
more of these seats that have been
announced so far but just look at the
chains labor up by over 200 uh slightly
less 200 when you take it in net terms
the conservatives down there when you
look at the bar and how that's traveling
down that way so negative over there
positive over and it's labor in positive
terms it's the lib Dems in positive
territory as well the greens in positive
territory as well and just look how few
they are losing at the same time and
then you've got some of the changes
obviously independent issues really
important within many of these councils
as well no less uh in particular when
we're talking about independent issues
uh then here in t side Middlesbrough and
a lot of these areas here were under no
overall control typically this is labor
heartlands and remember a lot of talk
recently wasn't there about the red wall
about how the Tories were going to come
in and take control at least in the
Parliamentary elections there well this
was all read up until a few years ago
and then it was painted in that kind of
gray signifying no overall control a lot
of Independence uh doing well there well
now look at that look at that red there
that is Middlesbrough so that's
Middlesbrough and that's just been
announced that has come back under labor
control and if we zoom out I'll just
show you some of the numbers because
they're you know they are pretty Stark
so here we have it Middlesbrough labor
game from no overall control so labor
taking control of it gaining five seats
it's this independent uh seats in
particular independent councilors that
have lost out and it's labor and indeed
actually the conservative party and the
lib dams who have gained as a result but
when you have a look at the kind of the
Electoral history in Middlesbrough this
goes all the way back to the 90s and you
can see just how much the labor vote was
gradually falling through the 90s into
the 2000s and look at what happened
recently in the kind of post-brexit
period you had this really big shift
this step shift in labor votes a big
rise in independent votes that kind of
red War Story started to emerge around
that time but now look that's the change
there that red line starting to overtake
again uh that Gray Line and labor taking
control of Middlesbrough now before we
were showing you a really interesting
way of looking at this looking at I
don't know what we call this whether
it's got a speedometer maybe for the
Tories you might call it the dial of
Doom because this is basically showing
how many of their seats they are losing
over the course of the evening into the
morning and just how bad that would be
versus expectations okay so that's the
starting point so zero in terms of the
change at about one o'clock we showed
you it had gone there so they were
moving down losing seats and this dial
was going down uh through from kind of
what would be if it were the end of the
night very good territory down into kind
of worst territory that's more or less
where they are now so the dial is kind
of going that way that way that way that
way that way and a lot of people think
that it could go all the way through to
over here around a thousand uh seats
lost across these elections so that's
the conservative party how about for the
labor party one the case of the labor
party it's all about increasing uh their
share increasing their number of seats
and that's where it was at the start
then it was up to about there at about 1
lock let's see where it is more or less
now that dial has gone further so it's
technically If This Were to stop now
that would be a bad result for the labor
party but we have so many more results
yet to come through what we do know so
far is looking pretty good for the labor
party give or take those kind of
anomalous results potentially in Slough
and other places a few other places as
well good for the lib Downs as well and
pretty disastrous for the conservative
party they were defending these at the
start of the night at the start of this
counts last time around this board this
entire board all of which are different
councils around England were blue this
was all blue and just look at it now
look at how many of these places have
gone from being blue to gray suggesting
that's no overall control to the yellow
for the lib Dems and red for the labor
party and this is only a selection of
some of the councils the conservative
party were defending it has been in
these results so far it's been pretty
disastrous and as I say there's still
many more results many more counts yet
to come we'll keep all of this updated
as that accounting continues back to you
Sophie thank you very much indeed Ed
there really bringing you up to speed
with all the numbers and it was as Eda
was saying we've got an awful lot of
council still to declare so there'll be
a few more twists in this story but the
narrative so far are very very difficult
performance for the conservative party
labor and the lab gems too making some
real strides it's been a busy day for
the royal family as well though so let's
take you to Belle Donati who is across
all of your coronation news
certainly um and welcome back to the
mall here on this eve of the king's
coronation uh we took you through uh
well about an hour ago you saw uh the
royal family going on a walkabout before
that because it has been a busy day for
them on the eve of the coronation before
that uh the king and uh Queen consort
were involved in rehearsals uh for
tomorrow's ceremony they were in
Westminster Abbey for those rehearsals
uh King Charles then hosted a lunch
reception that took place at Buckingham
Palace and that was with visiting
Commonwealth dignitaries the King was
joined by other senior members of the
royal family for that lunch along with
the Prime Minister urushi sunak and it
was from that lunch that we then saw the
royal family coming up the mall here we
were lucky with the weather for this
afternoon's walk about it just about
held off after a massive downpour just
before heavy rain in central London if
you were here you would have felt it and
it certainly means that if I look down
uh here on the mall everybody's feet are
pretty much covered in mud and wet we
have been given a look at some of the
ancient crown jewels which are going to
be used during the coronation you should
be seeing them now they include two
crowns that King Charles will wear
during the coronation one of those
crowns weighs over two kilograms but
before we come to tomorrow's coronation
we have a lot more waiting and a lot
more anticipation here on the mall we've
been with the crowds and we have two
members of the crowd here Lucy and Maz
who've been waiting when did you arrive
about seven o'clock this morning we got
here and how far did you come from I've
come from Manchester so I drove down
last night took about three and a half
hours and I drove to Mary's house so
we're just in Surrey so not too far and
was this planned oh yeah it's a lot of
planning and preparation months yeah
yeah we've been thinking about it what
was the Kit like what have you got to
sort of stay overnight two very lounging
chairs everybody's got real Envy of to
be fair and a big plastic sheet piece of
plastic that's coming quite handy this
morning when it was thundering and
lightning oh that's like a bit like a
greenhouse so you you were here I saw
you in the front row there for uh for
the Walkabout did you get to talk to
Prince Charles and enter Kate uh yeah we
spoke to William and Kate it was amazing
yeah not sorry not Prince Charles I do
apologize Prince William of course yes I
told Kate I like to dress she told us
she liked her crowns she said did we
make them and I said I did I was kindly
brought my crown from by my boss who
brought them into work and we made them
and worked the other day so and William
was asking saying about how it rained at
the last coronation I told him my dad
was actually at it so it was quite
interesting what does it mean for you to
be here is there a family connection for
you with your father having having been
at the last coronation well my parents
used to like to bring us up for things
so we were at the Silver Jubilee in 1977
when I was five and came up for Charles
and Diana's wedding to see them golf on
honeymoon so they were always on for
coming up and joining in so what about
for you Lucy um I've just come from like
having a fun day out really and staying
overnight it's just it's just something
quite bizarre to do and you know we're
British and we do crazy things like this
and it's just fun yeah
so I wonder about that is it are you
here because this is a moment in history
are you here because there's this quite
special atmosphere here what what does
it mean for you to make because it's not
an easy thing to stay overnight on very
hard floor I don't know I think it's
just a mix of everything and you'll
never get this opportunity again you
know so it's yeah I've always watched
them on the TV and thought I wish I'd
done it I wish and when we we saw the
Queen's funeral I did watch her her
coughing go by nearby our house I said
right that's it we're going up and we're
staying the night for the coronation so
and it's just yeah it's a moment in
history it's something the atmosphere is
incredible I think when we go back and
tell our friends they're all going to
want to come now
we're crazy and now they are it is
amazing it's amazing and have you made
friends here
[Music]
everyone's chat we're all sharing photos
that we took of each other when we
didn't like set up WhatsApp groups
already in that so it's like really fun
really nice what have you got for
tomorrow provision Squad food drink are
you is there champagne what's happening
tomorrow there is espresso martini
and then finish off with maybe a few
jagermeisters
um are you by any chance the type of
people go to festivals yeah yeah
how much does this atmosphere have in
common with a Great British Festival
yeah it's similar
yeah it's just different very different
yeah what is it about the royal family
for you because it's a big change now
going from uh Queen Elizabeth to King
Charles what does that feel for you how
what do you think is going to happen to
the royal family I I feel at the moment
that really moving with the times and I
think especially when we saw Kate and
will what I noticed when they went past
they really spent time to speak to
everybody that took a long time and that
is for me is a real move in the right
direction I think yeah yeah there's less
distance between yeah you know that you
wouldn't have got that close I think in
the past so yeah and when it comes to
the actual ceremony tomorrow will you be
watching that on your phones how are you
going to be going to be watching it
on the phones and then yeah and then
hopefully seeing them come out on the
balcony later and for the flyby
absolutely oh listen it's a pleasure to
talk to you thank you so much Lucy and
Maz I hope you stay vaguely dry tonight
there are a few spots of rain we've had
them coming in and out throughout the
course of the day we're hoping it might
stay uh dry and here with me is Alice
Porter who's also going to talk us
through tomorrow because of course this
is all about what's happening tomorrow
we're actually at the beginning aren't
we of the procession just talk us
through what we're going to see very
much so well like we saw with the
Queen's funeral we can expect everything
to to go along like absolute Clockwork
at 10 20 the king and the queen consort
will make their way down the mall and
they will be in the Diamond Jubilee
State coach and I think from speaking to
the fans people here in the crowds we
can expect an electric atmosphere as it
makes its way down the mile down to
Whitehall before finally arriving at
Westminster Abbey at about 11 o'clock
they'll be then the two hour coronation
service and then after that the newly
crowned king and queen will make their
way in the gold State coach which is
around 2 260 years old I mean this is
Pomp and pageantry and Splendor of the
the UK at its absolute finest they will
be then making their way the journey
back to about one and a half miles which
may sound long but if we look at the
Queen's coronation that was about four
miles long so this is sort of a little
bit more trimmed down there'll be around
4 000 military personnel that we can
expect I mean this is the largest
military ceremonial operation for 70
years so really extraordinary and
there'll be this incredible atmosphere
as the the coach makes its way along the
mall the uh the king's grandchildren
will be in a carriage behind them and
they'll make their way into Buckingham
Palace and then around course bars two
there'll be a fly pass from the Red
Arrows but also other military services
as well and I think really poignantly
and strikingly this will be the first
time that we will see the royal family
on the balcony of a belkinian palace
since the queen has died and I think
it'll be quite moving really to see the
family gather together without the queen
but I think this very much will Harold
this is a new air era really this is
with our new king he will be finally
crowned tomorrow it will be obviously so
exciting so many people here who've been
gathered uh for a number of days now
really to watch tomorrow's events which
will of course be so historic absolutely
thank you very much Alice and it is that
glimpse of the royal family the new
royal family uh up on the balcony that
so many here will be excited about
seeing and of course that's like concern
that actually some of the finer moments
of the coronation they will not get to
see potentially if phones give out so
hoping for technology to be on their
side as they try here in these crowds to
witness this moment in their history do
come back to us so we'll be here on the
mouth the rest of the afternoon see you
later
uh thanks very much Belle who will be
guiding us through all of that building
excitement as people wait for the
coronation
in other World Health Organization has
announced that covid-19 is no longer a
global Health Emergency
yesterday
the emergency committee met for the 15th
time and recommended to me that I
declare an end to the public health
emergency of international concern
I have accepted that advice
it's therefore with great hope that I
declare covid-19 over as a global Health
Emergency
we're joined Now by science
correspondent Thomas Moore
such a moment doesn't it after the last
few years that everyone has gone through
to hear those words been spoken yes it
turned our lives upside down and some
people endured horrific things that they
never thought would be possible in in
Modern Life and I think it has
recalibrated everything we deal with in
in society as a community but after
three years three months five days the
global Health Emergency is at a hit at
an end now the virus is still causing uh
one death every three minutes around the
world it has not gone but there is a
feeling now that it has retreated
sufficiently for the World Health
Organization to relax what is a formal
legal call for that requires countries
to act so it's dropping this what they
call a p Hickory a public health
emergency of international concern it is
now just considered a threat along with
many other viruses that of course that
we we deal with on a regular basis but
it is warning Nations not to drop their
guard that this virus could yet come
back that it needs that countries need
to make sure that they have all the
measures still in place should this or
another virus another pandemic virus
emerge and sweep the globe we need to
learn the lessons effectively is what
they're saying we can't be left standing
as we were in the spring of 2020 well
the virus ripped through Hospital Wards
turned cities into ghost towns and
really fundamentally changed everything
we thought we knew about Society
yeah absolutely extraordinary roller
coaster Thomas more thank you very much
indeed
you're watching Sky News coming up we'll
be taking a closer look at what we know
so far about the local election results
and what they could mean for Russia see
next political future
[Music]